Ukraine with highly controversial
cluster bombs saying it will not leave
the country defenseless
a green pint a brewery in South London
has created what it says is the first
carbon negative beer
in sports Andy Murray says he'll see if
he has the motivation to play at
Wimbledon again after losing in the
second round yesterday and a crucial day
ahead in the third ashes test with
England needing quick wickets at
headingley
in the weather a dry light sunny and hot
for England and Wales but the
possibility of a few heavy showers
and at 7 45 we'll take a look at this
morning's papers with International
marketing partner CEO Allison Stewart
Allen and PR and crisis management
expert Kevin Craig
[Music]
hello very good morning and welcome to
Sky News breakfast can police have been
accused of posting insensitive and
unacceptable tweets surrounding the
death of a 21 year old woman azra Kamal
died after falling from a dual
carriageway bridge and within hours the
police posted congratulatory messages
about their investigation using a scene
from the film Top Gun her mother has
told Sky News the Tweet was horrendous
Jason Farrell has this report
below the Medway viaduct in Kent Nettles
have reclaimed a shrine left in the
memory of azra Kamal
21 year old died here in July 2020
falling from the Dual carriageway Bridge
after her car broke down and caught fire
she was traveling back to London with a
male friend
paramedics had tried in vain to save
azra police were called to the scene but
azra's family were recently shocked to
discover what the police had tweeted in
the immediate wake of that investigation
Kent crime scene investigators
congratulate themselves on the speed of
their work using a gif from the movie
Top Gun characters Maverick and Goose
high five the words great teamwork as
they celebrate identifying the deceased
person within 90 minutes of being at the
scene
this is Ezra's mother Nevers
that tweet was just horrendous I could
not really could not believe that
professional police officers would
high-five themselves and Pat themselves
on the back on the back of my daughter's
demise it's more than insensitive it's
unacceptable that they think that they
can still the forensic team in Kent
think that that's acceptable what is the
mindset of people investigating crimes
on our behalf what is their mindset
another tweet celebrates the police
drone work with the hashtag cracking bit
of Kit and another reports within hours
that the police are satisfied there are
no suspicious circumstances even though
Ezra's mother is being told they're
still investigating
the initial suspect the man azra was
traveling with said that in the darkness
azra had not seen the drop as she
climbed over the central reservation
barrier he was released and the
investigation closed before the end of
the first day
strikes me that
murder investigation being open and
closed within 24 hours
not an adequate investigation I think
it's shocking that with an investigation
ongoing and in fact within a few hours
of of Never as having been informed of
her daughter's death the police would
brag about the expediency of the
investigation or the impressiveness of
their kids
ten police could have conducted what's
called a forensic post-mortem to look
for Clues as to whether anything
physical had happened at azra before she
fell but they instead did a standard
postmortem deciding that what happened
here was not suspicious
an independent review of azra's Case by
Essex police suggested a forensic level
postmortem would have helped avoid
unanswered questions by being able to
negate any third-party involvement and
that it may have been prudent to release
the suspect under investigation rather
than close the case
do the job that you're supposed to do
look at the information look at the
leads
look at the timelines look at the
interviews go back to the witnesses yeah
because no one saw azra die
in quest into azra's death returned a
verdict of misadventure Kent Police says
their investigation was full and
thorough and officers determined there
were no suspicious circumstances the
investigation by Essex police concluded
the service provided by Kent Police had
been acceptable
the independent office for police
conduct made the same conclusion
although that decision was appealed and
has been reopened the Tweet has been
removed and the complaint is being
reviewed by an independent police force
the family think this image reflects the
way things were investigated Jason
Farrell Sky News
the eight-year-old girl who died after a
Land Rover crashed into the grounds of
her primary school in Wimbledon has been
named as Selena Lao let's go straight to
our correspondent Alice Porter who's in
Wimbledon and Alice so this girl has
been named and heart-rending seeing the
photographs
it really is and I think the community
here in Wimbledon are really reeling
from the extraordinary tragic events
that took place on Thursday when a tea
party was just happening at the school
behind me and students were gathered and
it was then that the Land Rover made its
way through the fence here and collided
with the school and hitting a number of
children and sadly Selena Lao was the
eight-year-old girl who was tragically
killed and her family released a
statement yesterday through the
Metropolitan Police saying that she was
an intelligent and cheeky girl adored
and loved by everyone and a number of
people have been coming from the local
area to play for oral tributes to Selena
lau and they've been laying them here
over the last 24 hours or so many of
them naming her specifically there's
also another eight-year-old girl who's
also in hospital in a life-threatening
condition as well as a 40 year old woman
because a number number of people at the
scene had quite significant injuries we
know that 16 people were treated by the
London ambulance service but another 6
12 were also taken to hospital and we
know that some children had significant
injuries such as broken pelvises and I
think many people are just wondering
what exactly took place on Thursday and
what led to the Land Rover making its
way through the area behind me and into
the school at a time when children were
celebrating the end of term and enjoying
the good weather now we know a 46 year
old woman from Wimbledon has been
arrested on suspicion of causing death
by dangerous driving she's being
released on bail pending further
inquiries but I think many people here
in the local community are at a shop
really of what happened in broad
daylight and I think some of the the
pictures that really emerged from the
scene were really quite something we
really don't see very often but the
community here very much reeling from
the tragic events on Thursday that sadly
left an eight-year-old little girl dead
thanks very much indeed
the Pentagon has confirmed the U.S will
send cluster bombs to Ukraine as part of
a new military aid package Ukraine has
been asking for the weapons for months
the explosives are believed to pose a
high risk to civilians more than 100
countries have banned cluster Munitions
partly because the explosive bomblets
can remain undetonated in civilian areas
but the U.S national security adviser
Jake Sullivan said the U.S won't leave
Ukraine defenseless
we have provided Ukraine with a historic
amount of unitary artillery rounds and
we are ramping up domestic production of
these rounds we've already seen
substantial increases in production but
this process will continue to take time
and it will be critical to provide
Ukraine with a bridge of supplies while
our domestic production is ramped up we
will not leave Ukraine defenseless at
any point in this conflict period
well here's our U.S correspondent Mark
Stone
well President Biden said last night
that this decision was not easy and I
think that's a clear acceptance of just
how controversial the decision is
cluster Munitions are banned by most
countries around the world most of
America's NATO partner countries have
signed a convention Banning the use or
transfer of cluster bombs to other
countries the reason simply is because
of their indiscriminate Legacy the bombs
detonate above a Target Distributing
hundreds of smaller bomblets over a wide
area a proportion of them don't explode
and in past Wars they have killed mostly
civilians long after the wars have come
to an end worldwide it's estimated that
97 of cluster munition casualties are
civilians so why is America sending them
to Ukraine well I think it's a clear
indication that the war is not going
well for Ukraine the spring offensive
hasn't had the desired impact more
conventional artillery stocks are
running low and so the cluster bombs Act
as a bridge Supply until more
Conventional Weapons can be produced and
they would also have a big impact on the
battlefield wiping out dug in Russian
troops the Americans also argue that
their cluster Munitions are more
sophisticated than those the Russians
are already using on the battlefield
leaving fewer unexploded and they say
that on balance the Legacy risk to
civilians down the line from their bombs
is less than the risk to civilians now
from the Russian attacks still it is a
risky strategy it smacks of a war not
going well and some will argue that it
erodes America's claim to the moral High
Ground
you know of retired senior British army
officer Major General Rupert Jones a
very good morning to you thanks so much
for joining us this morning were you
surprised to hear that the US has
decided to send these controversial
cluster bombs to Ukraine is it the right
move in your view
I mean I wasn't surprised I mean there's
been discussion about this for an
extended period of time I would actually
take issue with your your correspondent
sense that this is evidence of the war
not going well I don't think it's that
at all all nations the United States
included have vexed very carefully
throughout the war about the moment to
provide different Munitions think about
the debate over giving thanks think
about the debate ever giving F-16
aircraft well it is an Evidence of is
that the the ukrainians have got a
shortage of ammunition and it is true
that the offensive is going slowly but
that doesn't mean it's not going well
the ukrainians have momentum but we know
they're short of Munitions and therefore
it doesn't surprise me and I confess I
think it's I think it's an entirely
valid decision to make president
zielinski will be using them on his own
soil not in another country's soil in
his own in his own country
and yet these are Munitions that are
banned by more than 120 countries and
they have caused controversy because of
their failure their Dodge rate meaning
that these unexploded small bombs can
Linger on the ground for years and so
many civilians can get caught up by them
yeah so there's a couple of things there
absolutely they've got they've got a bad
reputation of course the the Munitions
that the Americans are going to provide
have a much lower what people call dud
rate the Americans say about 2.5 percent
the the reality is after the war the
conflict zone is going to be
uninhabitable uh for a very significant
period of time think about other
conflict conflict zones uh Cambodia for
example where where you know it takes a
very long time to clear ordinance that
is going to be the case whether cluster
Munitions are used or not the the best
route for Ukrainian civilians to get
back to their life is to defeat Russia
and get the get their own towns and
cities back and this is this is a route
to that you say that the fact that the
US is sending cluster Ukraine isn't a
sign that the war is not going as well
as homes however we heard a lot about
Ukraine's spring counter-offensive in
the build up to it but how is that going
is it making slower progress than hopes
do you think
well of course you know not unreasonably
most of the chat about the offensive
before it came from International media
and and that's entirely right and proper
we would provide a huge amount of
equipment we've got vested interest in
in the in the offensive
but it wasn't the ukrainians bringing up
the offensive they were being very quiet
and cautious about it
look these things do take time the
ukrainians are trying to uh conduct this
offensive with one hand tied behind
their back if you like because they they
don't have fast gaps the idea that the
we Western nations were conduct an
offensive like this without significant
air power we just wouldn't the
ukrainians are trying to do that it's
really really hard they are making gains
incremental steady gains what they are
also doing is a thing that we don't see
so for example the deputy defense
minister uh hanumalia said two days ago
I think they they had just destroyed six
Russian Supply dumps in the zaparage
area so they're doing what they they've
done in other places where they they're
they're hitting the Russians behind
behind the front line they're destroying
the logistics they're just they're
hitting command nodes to make that make
the offensive easier for later
NATO's Gathering next week NATO agreed
in 2008 that Ukraine would become a
member but there's been no timeline or
Pathway to that we're now seeing reports
that the U.S president May back British
plans to Fast Track that membership
could that happen next week should that
happen next week yeah I mean for my
money I think presidents lenskies
um asked to the conference is is right
and proper he knows that they're
unlikely to get full uh or that I know
to get membership whilst the war is
going on but he wants an absolute
undertaking your future membership and a
pathway a fast track pathway uh laid out
I think that's a very reasonable uh
request and I I think we're very
disappointing if NATO don't back that
okay we'll wait and see what happens
there well Major General Rupert Jones we
appreciate your time this morning thanks
so much
well let's get more now on Ukraine
because Belarus has said it's prepared
to welcome the Wagner mercenary group as
part of what's thought to be a deal
agreed after their short-lived Mutiny in
Russia last month Sky News has been
given a tour of an abandoned Soviet
military base its rows of tents could
house thousands of Wagner Fighters if
they choose to move there but there's no
sign of them arriving yet our Moscow
correspondent Diana magnet has this
report from the military base outside
the belarussian capital Minsk
transparency apparently the order of the
day from the Belarusian Ministry of
Defense they promised they'd bring us
here to a base just south of Minsk and
here we are results
the only life we find a few men asleep
but they're Belarusian nothing to do
with Wagner Mercenaries
the Belarusian leader Alexander
lukashenko had told us on Thursday that
he'd offered the Wagner group this base
and they'd said no
we do not build camps we offered them
several former military camps but PMC
Wagner have a different vision of their
encampment
what that vision is he couldn't tell us
but if they do end up here there are 300
tents at their disposal enough for 5 000
troops
so what are the immediate plans for
who's going to live here and when are
they going to move in
our main goal is to set up the
infrastructure so that if in a situation
where we have to defend our country
militarily we have the infrastructure
so Wagner have not been here they have
visited but they'd be welcome if they
came that is the message that we're
getting nothing to see here except for a
large training facility set up very fast
for slightly ambiguous goals
construction started right around the
time that pregozian set his men on
Moscow satellite images showing nothing
here before prego's Mutiny two days
after though already a sprinkling of
tents
quiet is the nearby town of osipovic he
looks this is a military area belarus's
only ballistic missile Brigade The 465th
is based around here believed to have
recently taken delivery of Russian
nuclear-capable iskander missiles
it would make sense then for Russian
tactical nuclear warheads to have been
delivered here too but that are
Belarusian hosts would neither confirm
nor deny
dynamagne Sky News osipovici Belarus
let's take a look at some little stories
making the news this morning and it's
been reported that a well-known BBC
presenter has been taken off air over
claims of payments being made to a
teenager in exchange for sexually
explicit images the BBC says it takes
any allegations very seriously following
reports in the Sun newspaper that the
presenter has been accused of paying the
teenager more than 35 000 pounds for
sexual pitchers starting when they were
17.
the Dutch prime minister Mark Rutter has
resigned following the collapse of his
four-party coalition government the
prime minister announced that the
differences between the Coalition
Partners over migration policy were
irreconcilable he'll remain in office in
a caretaker capacity until a new ruling
Coalition is chosen
the former Manchester United goalkeeper
Edwin van der Sar is in intensive care
after suffering a bleed around his brain
the 52 year old who stepped down as
iax's chief executive earlier this year
is said to be in a stable condition
London Brewery says it's the first of
its kind to produce a carbon negative
beer without using carbon offsetting
it's using barley grown through
regenerative farming and it's capturing
the Hops that they're using Tom hee
reports while it may not look like it
this point is a little bit different
Brewers here in South London believe
it's the first carbon negative Point
without using any offsets like
pre-planting
possibly too early I've got to earn it
and why have you done this yeah we've
made this product because we want to
make great tasting beers that are
helping solve our climate crisis can you
show me how it's done yeah let's have a
look
secret is in the barley they're using
this is the Bali that we used to make
the beer has been grown in fields with
polycrops three different crops there's
no tilling there's no pesticides
herbicides none of that it's natural
when it comes to climate change what's
the difference between this barley and
normal so normal Bali per day for us has
of carbon footprint of about one ton of
CO2 whereas this barley has a comfort
print of minus seven tons great for the
ingredients all about the process let's
go and see we've got an innovation that
we're doing next door which is
recapturing the Hops that we use so the
beer's coming through this machine
and creating this dry powder work so
those are hops that have been used
already when we use hops we'll generally
grow half of Earth away like an orange
cut it in half reduce one half we'll
throw the other half away we're just
capturing that other half and making
sure we use that too
reducing the carbon intensity of beer
needs attention from growing of the
ingredients all the way through to the
brewing and the packaging and that's why
it's such a hard goal to reach Ben has
crunched the numbers what is carbon
negative here and what isn't yeah just
the beer and the kegs um as a packaging
type at the moment is carbon negative
we're looking to roll that out across
the cans and the beer and the cans as
well but it's going to take some changes
to packaging style and operationally to
to get that down so what is it that
makes the the kegs carbon negative and
potentially not the cows yeah so kegs
beer kegs are actually reusable so
they're just washed out and cleaned
comparatively to the cans that have to
be recycled which is energy intensive
which subsequently means a mission
intensive as well
I promise I'll be back
this beer is 10 more expensive so is the
demand there it's not just this Brewery
they're doing this we've seen some big
Brewers getting on this act they must
think there's an advantage there yeah
certainly I think moving towards carbon
neutral or moving towards carbon
negative is something which is going to
be increasingly important for breweries
the government have got set legal
targets by 2050 for all businesses to be
net zero emissions do we know if
customers are prepared to pay a little
bit more for climate friendly beer yet
um I don't know if we know the answer to
that exactly but we're we're certainly
seeing I mean the way that Gypsy Hill
have done it is to be really forward in
the way they're promoting to be you know
they're selling it as a carbon negative
lager they're putting it in there in The
Branding it's about educating consumers
helping them understand why if you use
higher quality ingredients if you use
lower environmental impact ingredients
and that is ultimately going to produce
a better beer but a lower impact beer
that's perhaps worth a bit more money
with breweries now also on the conveyor
belt towards net zero could Greener
pints soon be pulled at your local Tom
heat Sky News South London
and you can hear more about the climate
and the environment on the climate Show
with Tom that's at 3 P.M and 7 30 p.m
both today and tomorrow here on Sky News
let's take a look now at what the
weather's doing
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
or thunderstorms will push across
Britain and Ireland today giving some
torrential downpours and possibly
causing some disruption this morning
will be hot and humid for Central and
Eastern Parts but some of us are already
seeing some showers this morning those
showers will intensify as they push
Northeast
the vet office a warning that the
torrential rain and Gusty winds could
cause some disruption East Anglia should
remain largely dry until the afternoon
and the temperatures could hit 33
degrees making it the hottest day of the
year so far
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
we'll still come we have the sport with
Jackie who's at Wimbledon for us this
morning so uh Jackie morning to you what
have you got for us today then
well it was very disappointing yesterday
at Wimbledon for the Brits we'll be
looking back at that and also discussing
a little bit Andy Murray's future also
more heroics from Ben Stokes in the
ashes can England get quick wickets on
day three of the third ashes test
and Lewis Hamilton is hoping for huge
Improvement ahead of qualifying for the
British Grand Prix
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
they push the protesters further back
here there's around two or three hundred
still remaining
I'm Dan Whitehead and I'm Sky news's
West of England correspondent
this fan goes onto the streets of
Plymouth seven days a week 365 days a
year these facilities at the moment are
a lifesaver it's all the cotton
[Music]
from fishing communities to bustling
cities we spend every day reporting from
across the region hearing from people
who have real stories
I'm gonna have nowhere to live for
three or four months
there are still people inside the
properties here
they're coming from the epicenter of
what is now a global Health pandemic
seeing and speak and speak young women
who are selling themselves right on the
High Street it was desperately sad and
the fact it was happening right in the
heart of this community
before brexit these oysters were being
exported to the EU but the train stops
overnight
what's your feeling about the future
there Blake might all be
finished I don't know
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
so it's a bad day for the British
players at Wimbledon with an emotional
Andy Murray hinting that he may have
played his last match at the tournament
so let's go straight back to Jackie
beltrá who's in Wimbledon at Wimbledon
for us this morning and ducky is so sad
to see Andy Murray going out after such
a cracking start to his match against
Issa pass
no absolutely and it was very sad to see
him trudging up the hill to his rented
flat afterwards on his own just a very
lone figure it was um it was very sad
knowing how much work he'd put into this
one
um but you have to say sister pass was
the better man on the day I think if
Andy had been able to continue that
match deep into the night when it
started when he had the two sets to one
lead and he had the crowd on his side it
definitely perhaps would have gone his
way he had the momentum and then the
momentum was lost yesterday and since a
pass was was the more aggressive player
and I don't know he literally dropped
serve once Andy that's the only only
blip he made and that was it that was
the match gone over five sets four hours
and 40 minutes
um incredibly disappointing he puts a
lot of work into this more than most
players because of the metal hit and
although he told us before Wimbledon he
wants to continue for two more years he
was asked in the quest in the press
conference the question you know how
many more wimbledon's do you think you
you have
I don't know to be honest I'm obviously
very disappointed just now
um
yeah obviously you never know how many
opportunities you're going to get to
play
um here
of course and in the meantime Jackie no
better news to the rest of the the
British male players
no absolutely I mean most people didn't
give a second thought to come Nori's
match yesterday against Chris Eubanks
the young up and coming American player
and he really struggled from the very
beginning and he got to the semi-finals
here last year he hasn't quite
replicated that form and it's he's he's
paid for it he is out very
disappointingly in the second round
which does not reflect his world ranking
does not reflect his Wimbledon seeding
of 12.
um Chris Eubanks though had won a grass
Sports tournament coming into this so
perhaps a secret weapon for The
Americans really and knows his way
around the grass port for sure
so come Nori out in four sets the player
who did the best and reached the third
round and the scheduling here is all
over the place because of that terrible
rain delay at the beginning of the week
it was Liam Brody at the lowest ranks of
the three at 142 in the world using a
wild card this Wimbledon he lost
yesterday to Dennis Chapel varlov the
26th seed but it was a really good fight
previously he's put out Casper Rude the
fourth seed the number four in the world
had an incredible tournament and has
given himself Financial cushioning
really for the rest of the year and
enough points hopefully to get into the
grand slams for the rest of the year so
for him although he lost a very very
successful Wimbledon a very very good
Wild Card indeed
so over to Katie Balter she is the last
British singles player left she will
play The Wimbledon champion Elena
Rebecca later on today on Center Court
can she do it she's been in great form
won the mixed doubles with her boyfriend
Alex De Manor yesterday perhaps she can
she's the last one standing that's
Wimbledon but there is so much more
sport going on this weekend let's have a
quick look
my new sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality
getting more people more active live
life with vitality
every week across the UK 85 of
school-aged students take part in
approximately an hour of sport a week
organize Grassroots sport has lower
numbers but it translates to millions of
girls and boys between the age of 7 and
20 playing sport
but there is a problem
a big problem without doubt every year
we seem to be seeing more and more young
people coming through with significant
knee injuries and primarily we're
talking about ACL ruptures the numbers
are staggering and extremely worrying
for every one person that was having an
ACL reconstruction in the late 90s
there's now 29 children
having those surgeries so the number of
injuries is without a doubt 29-fold yeah
evidence of a problem comes from
multiple sources other surgeons and
doctors are waving a warning flag we
increased by 29 folds amount of
operation devastating injuries that are
that that can cause complete changes
over their life trajectory and early
risk of arthritis
people are committing to one or two
sports at most at the moment if they are
going to be part of the local community
and they they spend less time developing
other skills that would be naturally
developed when they are participating in
multiple Sports they're on screens
sedentary and then suddenly they're in
very organized highly competitive Sports
environments there's
some evidence about you know sport
specialization so if you have a a child
who's very good at one sport they might
be pushed down that kind of route and
only play that sport probably second
biggest reason is that there is a huge
knowledge Gap in the UK about the
importance of injury prevention programs
and the importance of warming up kids
there's this myth in Grassroots sport
that kids don't get injured so they
don't need to warm up just you know get
off on the pitch and off you go it
couldn't be farther from the truth you
look at Australia you look at some of
the Scandinavian countries Netherlands
Canada all of them have started trying
to put together National programs to
deliver these warm-up programs and in
the UK that really hasn't happened it's
embarrassing to say that we're from the
UK we are so behind the rest of the
world female footballers are six times
more at risk of an ACL injury while
research and data is lacking young
female athletes across the board are
more susceptible to the injury than boys
and young men for 20 years we have known
that there's an increased ACL injury
rate in women and girls compared to men
and boys the anatomical side of things
is what makes it more likely to rupture
the actual rupture is identical whether
you're male or female it's been
overloaded what are the factors impact
that ligament the obvious one to mention
first is there's a menstrual cycle
um and that appears to have some impact
on injury
um there's a fluctuation of hormones
through the menstrual cycle it's just
not the full picture it contributes but
we don't yet understand there's a
nuanced gender issue there that just
needs a bit of exploring is it about
attitudes to girls
um being Physically Active around that
age is it accessibility opportunity to
to stay Physically Active when they
become teenagers we don't this guy knew
Sports bulletin is brought to you by
vitality
Jackie thanks very much indeed you're
watching Sky News breakfast coming up
we're going to be speaking to the green
parties transport spokesman about the
future of electric Motoring
and we'll also discuss what's putting
people off buying electric cars
[Music]
foreign
everything
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
first now it's been reported today that
the country is still way behind in its
preparations for the change to electric
cars by 2030 the charging network is
insufficient and filling up electric
cars in public places could be very
expensive even more than the cost of
filling up with petrol and yet almost
one in five new cars being sold are now
electric so let's get the thoughts of
Matt Edwards who's the green party's
transport spokesperson very good morning
to you thanks so much for talking to us
it's clear that the government wants to
promote a switch to electric cars
they've announced that there'll be a ban
on the sale of new petrol and diesel
cars after 2030 and yet reports today
that Westminster the borough the London
borough of Westminster has more electric
car chargers these are the public ones
than six major cities in the north and
Midlands combined what's your reaction
to that do you find that concerning
um well I'm not sure it is very clear
that the government wants to drive this
switch to Electric cause for example the
reasons that you've said we've got a lot
of
um the charging infrastructure certainly
in the north of England where I'm a
councilor
um is inadequate and there is just not
enough investment
and there's also a bit of inconsistency
in planning policy it's when when you
either retail commercial or residential
buildings
um are being built there's no
necessarily um Drive the the drive to
install electric charging points is
patching it depends from Capital to
council
and that's an issue
well yes and the government does have
targets for trying to bolster its
charging infrastructure but you're
raising questions about whether or not
it'll achieve those targets what about
the issue that electric prices are so
high at public at charging points it can
be more expensive to to recharge a car
than fill up with petrol now how do you
persuade people to make the green choice
if that persists well I mean that that
exactly should be the point the greenest
option and we would say that the
greenest option the one that's best for
the planet should be the cheapest the
most convenient and at the moment with
electric cars that's not very clear
um many people don't know the cost of
charging electric car
um in public
um and it is just a massive barrier and
then the there's still this kind of
older perception that actually the
connections people people are unsure of
that they're not sure whether they can
use all electric charging function it we
just need more better communication on
that sort of thing
in the meantime the London mayor Sadiq
Khan is introducing an expansion of the
it's called the Euless Zone anyone
outside London might not know so much
about it but it's this ultra low
emission Zone where people get penalized
for driving polluting cars within that
zone it's it's gonna become three times
bigger do you think that's the right
thing to do during a cost of living
crisis
um
I mean if we look at the what the
problem that the Ule said is trying to
solve is trying to solve air pollution
um air pollution certainly London and in
many urban areas is a really significant
issue what we've got though is
um a lack of coherent strategy from the
government so we have media reactions to
a lot of things and what we really need
is some joined up thinking where we're
not only putting barriers in people's
way and we're actually putting Solutions
London actually has very good public
transport compared to a lot of the
country certainly Bradford where I am
we're seeing a lot of cuts to public
transport and we have a cleaner Zone and
here as well and it only affects
commercial vehicles
um but straight away we're putting
barriers in people's way without
actually putting the solutions
um and that's not right
but in the meantime until those
Solutions or that there's more public
transport available to people is it
right to to extend
um a Zone like this a an ultra low
emission Zone when there's a cost of
living crisis people are struggling to
pay their bills well well exactly but a
lot of people who as part of that not a
lot of people
um Drive we're still seeing in the
country 30 40 of people don't drive why
is it that the and these are often the
people that are living in areas with the
worst air pollution we need to we we
there does need to be more joined up
thinking to this and look I mean
obviously I'm a northern councilor so
knowing the ins and outs of the Wellies
I'm not
researching on that but we do need to
actually think much more coherently
about this problem
on the subject of Justin Paul I want to
ask you about that because we've seen
protests at the ashes we've seen
protests at Wimbledon this week and now
Lewis Hamilton has said that he would
support a peaceful protest by just stop
oil at uh this weekend's British Grand
Prix do you agree with them would you
like to see one do you think they're
right to do one I mean peaceful protests
that's a democratic right that we have
regardless of what people protest on
we've seen people peaceful protests
about and the ulez as well that's
everyone's Democratic right to do that
um disruption
um yeah I don't have an issue with peace
or protest
well yes and yeah we've seen the Home
Secretary swella bravman condemning just
stop oil's protests at Wimbledon is
unacceptable for example she said that
protesters are selfish
um she said their intent on spoiling our
sporting occasions this summer do you
think she's got a point there
did she have the same thing to say about
the oil is that protests did you have
the same thing to say about the protests
about outside the South and outside
Asylum centers we're not we you can't
just say we don't like protests about a
particular thing we don't like you've
got to either as a country we have um
peaceful protest is a democratic right
that's Universal we can't pick and
choose the
um the values behind that
so you back just off oils methods of
protest do you think they're effective
oh well I'm back peace or protest that's
um I don't necessarily
everything that just stop oil has said
but I do back piece or protest is it
effective we're talking about it that's
the whole point
um things like the ULU said we're
talking about it because there are
um protests it is something it is a way
of getting things on the agenda
okay well Matt Edwards um green party
councilor the party's uh transport
spokesman thanks very much indeed thank
you
thank you the weather's doing that
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well thunderstorms will push across
Britain and Ireland today giving some
torrential downpours and possibly
causing some disruption this morning
will be hot and humid for Central and
Eastern Parts but some of us are already
seeing some showers this morning those
showers will intensify as they push
Northeast the Met Office are warning
that the torrential rain and Gusty winds
could cause some disruption East Anglia
should remain largely dry until the
afternoon and temperatures could hit 33
degrees making it the hottest day of the
year so far
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
do you say weather's coming up we're
going to take a look at this morning's
papers with International marketing
Partners chief executive Allison Stewart
Allen and the pr on crisis management
expert Kevin Craig
[Music]
uh I think octopuses are fascinating in
a number of different ways probably one
of the things that's interesting about
them is they're sort of considered in
some ways an honorary vertebrate in the
sense that they're closely related to
the other mollusks which are snails and
slugs but they're very fast in their
behavior and they act a little bit
um like many of the vertebrates do and
we sort of have this pride of place as
vertebrates ourselves and so they're
very interesting but distantly related
animal to us they're similar to humans
in many ways because uh all animals are
we have very common things that run very
deep in uh evolutionary history amongst
the animals and so you know we all
um we all need food we all fear
predators and look for shelter we all
need to find mates for the most part so
there's some very deep animal
commonalities but there's been some
recent work uh in outside of my field
but related to octopuses
that have shown that they're um they're
some of their brain functions some of
their genetics uh are doing things that
are very similar to what uh what we do
uh octopuses use this um this reaching
behavior in a number of different ways
and one of the ways that they uh use
this behavior is to sort of reach out
and investigate or sometimes discourage
um to discourage other animals that are
investigating the food the octopus is
working on and so
um you know I wasn't involved in that
study
um but but that's that's generally
what's going on I made a documentary
with uh
PBS here in the United States and BBC
uh over your way that uh in BBC I always
believe it was called
um the octopus in my uh living room and
uh it's an exploration of of octopuses
but from a particular point of view that
that I found interesting which is how do
they relate to other animals they're
they're famously solitary and yet you
know we uh I kept an octopus in the
house and my daughter and I took care of
her and um you know she really seemed to
to uh be very engaged in interacting
with us and it raises some interesting
questions to me about why is this
solitary animal also so skilled at
interacting with other beings foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
do you know what kind of pollen gets up
your nose
Sky News pollen reports brought to you
by the kleenex your pollen Pal app
well Saturday will be hot and humid
across parts of Scotland England and
Eastern Wales at first elsewhere there
will be already a few showers and these
will spread eastwards turning
increasingly heavy and thundery as they
do so there's also the chance of seeing
some hail and some Gusty winds and the
thunderstorms could cause some
disruption despite the showers pollen
levels everywhere are expected to be
high the exception being some western
parts of Scotland where it'll be
cloudier and there'll also be some
stronger winds
Sky News pollen reports brought to you
by the kleenex your pollen Pal app
so time for us to take another look at
the morning papers here with me
reviewing them today are Alison and
Stuart Allen chief executive of
international marketing partners and
Kevin Craig PR and crisis management
experts so welcome back to both of you
thank you and we didn't get to all the
front pages there's one that you had
wanted to talk to in the last hour Kevin
that we're going to deal with now this
is um the expresses front page the
headline is Rishi ERD urged time to talk
up brexit so who's doing the urging well
it's uh he's being urged principally the
call is being led by Brendan Clark Smith
who's one of the Tory MPS to get elected
last time in the law in Labor's red wall
and it's a really interesting story and
it's not just a Fantasia goes right
across the paper leader inside several
Pages big coverage because Rishi is
being told talk up the benefits of
brexit you know we got elected on this
in 2019 you know we're not giving it
enough Positive Vibes says you know an
MP who ultimately you know owes his seat
to that and of course It's Tricky for
Rishi if that's a slogan because you
know we see this week 55 five percent of
people think brexit was a bad idea to 34
there's a thing called regret like what
they've done there you know people who
think again and the express is
unashamedly
um and always has been a pro-brexit
newspaper and its leader today is very
very hardcore it's very explicit you
know stick with the Tories talk up
brexit come on Rishi but interestingly
in the big coverage inside the only
voice that they could say and to for
balance the quote is
um Chris Chris Hayward uh policy
chairman of the city of London claim
there are now thousands of extra jobs in
the city as a result of brexit but
actually it doesn't tell us that he's a
former conservative Deputy leader of a
council in in the south west so it's a
it's a bold line by the express but the
numbers I don't think Russia is going to
be taking that advice anytime soon and
yet there will be MPS that as you say
feel that they got their
that got elected because of brexit and
so the government needs to yes there
will be talk it up because that's how
they felt and they may feel that's how
their prospects of hanging on to their
seats yeah it goes well let's move on to
the financial times um Allison because
there's a story in here about
this this ongoing battle between these
two billionaires yes essentially yes I
mean the headline is Clash of the tech
Titans and their ego yes I think egos is
the operating operative word in this
headline so basically it's about the
Zuckerberg V musk uh contest for online
Supremacy I mean for most people you
know getting on with your daily life
worrying about the cost of living crisis
uh this is almost the bread and circuses
part of of daily life now uh in effect
Zuckerberg has launched a Twitter rival
service called threads only a few days
ago already has millions of users
supposedly signed up what isn't made
obvious in this story is the fact that
you are instantly given a threads
account if you have an Instagram account
so basically uh you haven't made a
choice to sign up for this Twitter
look-alike you are automatically
enrolled in the program number one
number two the reason that this is a
story is because
both these platforms Twitter and now
threads are Keen to capture more of your
spending it's as simple as that so they
want to both integrate shopping AI
uh let's see
um payments uh make it easy to do
payments and pay other people besides
pay retailers and really it's a battle
for eyeballs I mean social media
platforms is all about eyeballs how many
people can we get to sign up so legal
action now absolutely yeah there's lots
of legal action I mean both but let's
just say both of their reputations uh I
mean we were talking in the last hit
about uh trust you know both of these
brands have been compromised in terms of
Which online platform should I trust for
a variety of reasons it could be
Cambridge analytica it could be some of
musk's Maneuvers in clearing out staff
at Twitter uh and now the moderation
teams who are supposed to pay attention
to harmful content are left with a
skeletal number of people in the
function so both of them have a lot of
problems uh and so to distract us by
saying oh let's have a cage fight in Las
Vegas as they're supposedly suggesting
they will do firstly I would pay a lot
of money to go see that I'll say yeah
who's your money on uh musk for sure
what in a fight
well we need to see it yeah bring it on
and I didn't know that you automatically
actually got signed up yes you were on
Instagram I thought it made it easier
access but you still have to I'm engaged
well I have it on good authority that
that's the case that you're
automatically enrolled and given a
threads account oh okay and let's move
on to um the times Kevin because there's
an article here about the smps call for
decriminalizing drugs which was uh
knocked back by a government in
Westminster yeah and a really
interesting story inside the paper page
two I think um because it reminds us
that Scotland uh Scotland's drug death
rate is the um worst in Europe and the
Scottish government has called for the
decriminalization of all drugs for
personal use and you know there is a lot
of policy substance and experience
behind this call of course and we're you
know 18 months out from a general
election neither Rishi sunak or
kirstarma this is not the time for for
bold moves on on decriminalization of
drugs it would be political suicide for
both of them and they knocked it back
quite quickly but it's um you know I I
think the there's a conservative
um MSP who's you know calling it from
the s p deeply cynical attempt uh to
create you know constitutional division
but I actually think that
um they are wrestling with big deep
seated issues up there other European
countries have liberalized drug use
Canada has and I think after a next
general election I think it'll be really
interesting because let's face it if
alcohol was invented today for the first
time given the damage it causes to our
society it would be treated differently
yeah that's a very interesting problem
yeah it would and have we got time
Allison very quickly to look at Tick
Tock and we've only got 20 seconds I
don't know if we have
debut author shoots the number one on
Amazon after viral Tick Tock yes yes
we'll visit that next time we're going
to have to now let's not forget anyway
Alice and Kevin lovely to chat to you
and I'll see you again in an hour's time
do you stay with us we've got all the
top stories coming out next
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello it's eight o'clock you're watching
Sky News breakfast these are our top
stories here this morning insensitive
and unacceptable a grieving mother says
she's appalled by Top Gun style tweets
posted by Kent Police hours after her
daughter was found dead what is the
mindset of people investigating crimes
on our behalf what is their mindset
the schoolgirl killed after a car
crashed into her school in Wimbledon is
named as eight-year-old Selena Lau
police investigations are continuing
here as the community remains deeply
shot by the accident in which Selena
died
the US is to provide Ukraine with highly
controversial cluster bombs saying it
will not leave the country defenseless
Auntie Marie says he'll see if he still
has the motivation to compete at
Wimbledon again after losing in the
second round
and in the ashes England in search of
quick wickets on day three of the must
win third test at headingley
in the weather dry sunny and hot for
England and Wales with the possibility
of a few heavy showers
and at 8 45 we'll take a look at this
morning's papers with International
marketing Partners boss Allison Stewart
Allen and PR and crisis management
expert Kevin Craig
foreign
good morning and welcome to Sky News
breakfast Kent Police have been accused
of posting insensitive and unacceptable
Tweeds surrounding the death of a 21
year old woman azra Kamal died after
falling from a dual carriageway bridge
and within hours the police posted
congratulatory messages about their
investigation using a scene from the
film Top Gun her mother has told Sky
News the Tweet was horrendous Jason
Farrell has this report
below the Medway viaduct in Kent Nettles
have reclaimed a shrine left in the
memory of azra Kamal
a 21 year old died here in July 2020
falling from the jewel carriageway
Bridge after her car broke down and
caught fire she was traveling back to
London with a male friend
paramedics had tried in vain to save
azero police were called to the scene
but azra's family were recently shocked
to discover what the police had tweeted
in the immediate wake of that
investigation
Kent crime scene investigators
congratulate themselves on the speed of
their work using a gif from the movie
Top Gun characters Maverick and Goose
high five the words great teamwork as
they celebrate identifying the deceased
person within 90 minutes of being at the
scene
this is Ezra's mother Nevers that tweet
was just horrendous I could not really
could not believe that professional
police officers would high-five
themselves and Pat themselves on the
back on the back of my daughter's demise
it's more than insensitive it's
unacceptable that they think that they
can still the forensic team in Kent
think that that's acceptable what is the
mindset of people investigating crimes
on our behalf what is their mindset
another tweet celebrates the police
drone work with the hashtag cracking bit
of kid and another reports within hours
that the police are satisfied there are
no suspicious circumstances even though
Ezra's mother is being told they're
still investigating
the initial suspect the man azra was
traveling with said that in the darkness
azra had not seen the drop as she
climbed over the central reservation
barrier he was released and the
investigation closed before the end of
the first day
strikes me that
an investigation being open and closed
within 24 hours
not an adjective investigation I think
it's shocking that with an investigation
ongoing and in fact within a few hours
of of Never as having been informed of
her daughter's death the police would
brag about the expediency of the
investigation or the impressiveness of
their kids
10 police could have conducted what's
called a forensic post-mortem to look
for Clues as to whether anything
physical had happened to azra before she
fell but they instead did a standard
post-mortem deciding that what happened
here was not suspicious
an independent review of azra's Case by
Essex police suggested a forensic level
postmortem would have helped avoid
unanswered questions by being able to
negate any third-party involvement and
that it may have been prudent to release
the suspect under investigation rather
than close the case
do the job that you're supposed to do
look at the information look at the
leads
look at the timelines look at the
interviews go back to the witnesses yeah
because no one saw azra die
in quest into Ezra's death returned a
verdict of misadventure Kent Police says
their investigation was full and
thorough and officers determined there
were no suspicious circumstances the
investigation by Essex police concluded
the service provided by Kent Police had
been acceptable
the independent office for police
conduct made the same conclusion
although that decision was appealed and
has been reopened the Tweet has been
removed and the complaint is being
reviewed by an independent police force
the family think this image reflects the
way things were investigated Jason
Farrell Sky News
well let's get the reaction now of
police commentator Graham wetton who's
here with me morning to you Graham um
what do you make of this tweet by police
apparently congratulating themselves on
the speed of their work using a gift
from a Top Gun movie we heard there the
girl's mother saying it's more than
insensitive it's it's unacceptable do
you agree yeah I'd agree with it I I
think it is a difficulty for police in
here is trying to keep the public
informed and putting information out in
a public domain that informs people
what's happened this isn't informative
it doesn't stick to the facts it becomes
almost like self-congratulatory about
what's happened uh using images from
from movies Etc I don't think it's
acceptable at the time or at the in the
in the circumstances that we saw here
and it's not the first time that there
have been tweets or social media posts
that are deemed inappropriate or
insensitive is there a culture problem
in the police where officers don't
consider victims families or victims
themselves enough I think it's a
cultural issue I think they do consider
the families but the balance or the
difficult you got here is that a lot of
these communications by the
communications teams which are more than
that often not not police officers so
the link there has to be between the
investigation team and the
Communications Department uh putting out
specific information relevant
information and factual information
that's why you quite often see the
police put out messages saying we're not
going to release anything until we've
established the facts or the truth
that's the balancing because you don't
then want speculation on social media so
you almost got to stop the speculation
from starting by putting something out
but what you put out has to be factual
and has to be based on on what you've
established at that particular time so
the difficulty there is is that link
between the investigation team and the
communication team well yes and the Met
police is actually Banning its offices
from having social media apps on their
official phones I think they can use
WhatsApp for communications which is
more of a messaging service but that you
can't upload
um these smartphones with social media
apps as I understand it does that sound
like a good move yeah it does my
understanding as well they've issued
offices with specific almost like job
phones phones related to their work and
they've restricted certain apps on there
to stop them posted messages and going
on to these sort of sites so this
restricting their use of some social
media apps and trying to almost restrict
it to the official Communications that
come out well yes and there is an issue
issue with trust in the police at the
moment it's it's it some would say an
all-time low I mean what does this do to
to that levels of trust in the public
yes
ultimately the investigation team should
be working to establish a truth to see
it's exactly what's happened and the
facts are the case and putting out a
balanced communication line this didn't
seem balanced to me it's under
investigation rightly so
um but it does impact on trust again and
policing has to rebuild trust well yes
and some people would say that social
media is a way of communicating with the
community so can it be a useful tool if
done properly yeah absolutely it is
essential policing has to get up to in
line with modern modern methods of
communication and these social media
apps or modern methods of communication
policing it has to get ahead of the game
here make sure what they put out is is
true and factual but it's a key part of
policing it's that message that gets out
there the first message that goes out is
quite often the one that people then
then hang on to as being the actual true
story of what's happened so policing
needs to get um ahead of the game here
and understand how these apps and these
communications work okay Graham Wesson
always interesting to get your thoughts
thanks very much indeed
now the eight-year-old girl who died
after a Land Rover crashed into the
grounds of her primary school in
Wimbledon has been named as Selena Lao
our correspondent Alice Porter is in
Wimbledon for us now so this little girl
named Alice photographs have been issued
that many people will have seen on the
front pages of their newspapers this
morning at just such sad news
it really is and I really get his sense
here in Wimbledon that this is a
community who are just reeling from the
tragic events of Thursday we've had lots
of dog walkers people local people in a
community who've come to just stand
outside the school really in utter shock
at what had happened many of them are
looking at some of the floral tributes
which have been placed in front of the
school there's around 200 or so many of
them have accompanying notes and I think
a particularly difficult detail is to
see that many of them were written by
children and you can see them in their
children's handwriting that they say
phrases like Selena I will miss you and
I think it really brings home that this
is a little girl an eight-year-old girl
who tragically lost her life after a
Land Rover made its way through the
barrier here and into the school grounds
when we understand there was a tea party
celebrating the end of term and that's
why so many students were gathered
outside the school and it's also why
there were so many injuries we of course
had had Selena Who tragically died but
another eight-year-old girl and a 40
year old woman are in hospital currently
in a critical condition but there were
many people who were also treated at the
scene 16 people were treated by the
London ambulance service but another 12
were also taken to hospital and I think
questions really remain now exactly what
happened on Thursday we know that a 46
year old woman has been arrested on
suspicion of death causing death by
dangerous driving she has been released
pending further investigations but I
think many people will want answers to
know exactly what happened last Thursday
which unfortunately killed a little
eight-year-old girl
Alice thanks very much indeed
the Pentagon has confirmed the U.S will
send cluster bombs to Ukraine as part of
a new military aid package Ukraine's
been asking for the weapons for months
the explosives are believed to pose a
high risk to civilians more than 100
countries have banned cluster Munitions
partly because the explosive bomblets
can remain undetonated in civilian areas
but the U.S national security adviser
Jake Sullivan said the U.S won't leave
Ukraine defenseless
we have provided Ukraine with a historic
amount of unitary artillery rounds and
we are ramping up domestic production of
these rounds we've already seen
substantial increases in production but
this process will continue to take time
and it will be critical to provide
Ukraine with a bridge of supplies while
our domestic production is ramped up we
will not leave Ukraine defenseless at
any point in this conflict period
Belarus has said it's prepared to
welcome the Wagner mercenary group as
part of what's thought to be a deal
agreed after their short-lived Mutiny in
Russia last month Sky News has been
given a tour of an abandoned Soviet
military base its rows of tents could
house thousands of Wagner Fighters if
they choose to move there but there's no
sign of any arriving yet our Moscow
correspondent Diana magnet has this
report from the military base outside
the belarussian capital Minsk
transparency apparently the order of the
day from the Belarusian Ministry of
Defense they promised they'd bring us
here to a base just south of Minsk and
here we are
the only life we find a few men asleep
but they're Belarusian nothing to do
with Wagner Mercenaries
the Belarusian leader Alexander
lukashenko had told us on Thursday that
he had offered the Wagner group this
base and they'd said no
we do not build camps we offered them
several former military camps but PMC
Wagner have a different vision of their
encampment
what that vision is he couldn't tell us
but
if they do end up here there are 300
tents at their disposal enough for five
thousand troops
so what are the immediate plans for
who's going to live here and when are
they going to move in
our main goal is to set up the
infrastructure so that if in a situation
where we have to defend our country
militarily we have the infrastructure
so Wagner have not been here they
haven't visited but they'd be welcome if
they came that is the message that we're
getting nothing to see here except for a
large training facility set up very fast
for slightly ambiguous goals
construction started right around the
time that pregozian set his men on
Moscow satellite images showing nothing
here before pregozins Mutiny two days
after though already a sprinkling of
tents
quiet is the nearby town of osipovic he
looks this is a military area belarus's
only ballistic missile Brigade The 465th
is based around here believed to have
recently taken delivery of Russian
nuclear-capable iskandar missiles
it would make sense then for Russian
tactical nuclear warheads to have been
delivered here too but that are
Belarusian hosts would neither confirm
nor deny
dynamagne Sky News osipovici Belarus
let's take a look at what the weather's
up to now
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well thunderstorms will push across
Britain and Ireland today giving some
torrential downpours and possibly
causing some disruption this morning
will be hot and humid for Central and
Eastern Parts but some of us are already
seeing some showers
this morning those showers will
intensify as they push Northeast the Met
Office a warning that those torrential
rain and Gusty winds could cause some
disruption East Anglia should remain
largely dry until the afternoon and
temperatures could hit 33 degrees which
would make it the hottest day of the
year so far
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
what's not to come we've got the sport
with Jackie who's at Wimbledon for us
this morning so Jackie what have you got
for us
well I've got a lot of disappointment
that's what I've got at Wimbledon it was
a very disappointing for the British Men
Yesterday and we'll be looking at Andy
Murray's future after he went out in
round two uh what about the ashes how
are they going well there was more
heroics from Ben Stokes yesterday with
the bats England though new quick
wickets today
at headingley
and Lewis Hamilton is hoping for a huge
improvements ahead of qualifying for the
British Grand Prix
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Still Remains
I'm Dan Whitehead and I'm Sky news's
West of England correspondent
this fan goes onto the streets of
Plymouth seven days a week 365 days a
year these facilities at the moment are
a lifesaver that's all we've got
[Music]
from fishing communities to bustling
cities we spend every day reporting from
across the region hearing from people
who have real stories
I'm gonna have nowhere to live for
three or four months
there are still people inside the
properties here
they are coming from the epicenter of
what is now a global Health pandemic
we were seeing and speaking to young
women who were selling themselves right
on the High Street it was desperately
sad and the fact it was happening right
in the hearts of this community
before brexit these oysters were being
exported to the EU but the trade stopped
overnight
your feeling about the future there
Blake might OB
V finished I don't know
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
so it was a bad day for the British
players at Wimbledon with an emotional
Andy Murray hinting that he may have
played his last match at the tournament
so let's go straight to a Jackie
beltrell who's at Wimbledon for us this
morning and so disappointing to see Andy
Murray going out like that when he had
such a brilliant start to that match
against Issa pass
it was really sad actually just watching
trudging up the hill to his rented
apartments and afterwards all alone
cutting a very very dejected
disappointed figure and he was you're
right he was well in control of that
match when they they'd closed the roof
and then they'd call time on it because
there's a curfew here at 11 o'clock you
can't play Beyond it because of the
residents so they they call time of the
match with him in the ascendancy winning
two sets to one and then when he came
back yesterday to finish it off he just
didn't have the same intensity he didn't
really feel it was quite as passionate
from the crowd either he could really
feed off them as much I don't know there
was just something missing and sit
surpass was inspired in the end played
some brilliant tennis served
fantastically well with an amazing
forehand and it was just too much for
Murray only made one mistake in one game
and that was it that's all that's all it
took to to create such huge
disappointment and defeat and you know
in the press conference afterwards
um having worked so hard for this one
and got himself in really really good
place with his tennis I think it was
very hard to take he was asked how many
more wimbledon's have you got left and
he said this
I don't know to be honest um I'm
obviously very disappointed just now
um
yeah obviously you never know how many
opportunities you're going to get to
play
um here
you're just like so dejected doesn't he
Jackie let's hope he comes back I think
a lot of people miss him if he didn't in
the meantime not great news for the rest
of the British players either
no it was awful actually cam Nora didn't
even give that much a second thought
really against Chris Eubanks of the
states I thought you know cam will have
way too much pedigree and experience on
grass to get through this one but not at
all the young American saw him off in
four sets Cam said afterwards he wasn't
really feeling it he wasn't sort of
hitting the ball cleanly the way he
wanted to and it just was one of those
days where just things didn't go right
in the 12th seed who made the
semi-finals here last year very very
disappointingly not even reaching the
first weekend of Wimbledon this time uh
I suppose the star of the men's draw as
far as the Brits are concerned was he in
Brodie yes he lost yesterday but he was
playing in the third round he got
further than any of them the 142 in the
world really outplaying his actual
ranking he lost in the end to Dennis
shappavalov who won the Juniors here
some years ago and is the 26th seed and
uh a really highly rated talented player
but Brody's done really well he put out
the fourth seed in the previous round
he's had a brilliant Wimbledon he's owed
a fair bit of money and it's set him up
for the year he should be able to now
with the new ranking get into the grand
slams for the rest of the year and also
the cash will come in very handy with
all his traveling and sustaining his
tennis so he has had the best of the
times along with Petey Bolter who's also
into the third round she plays The
Wimbledon champion Elena Rebecca later
on today and she is the last British
player standing so good luck to her you
never know it could be the Katie boulter
show again
so that's the tennis all in all uh not
not a great fun story but what's
happening in the rest of the sports
let's have a look
the Sky News sports bulletin is brought
to you by Vitality getting more people
more active live life with vitality
every week across the UK 85 percent of
school-age students take part in
approximately an hour of sport a week
organize Grassroots sport has lower
numbers but it translates to millions of
girls and boys between the age of 7 and
20 playing sport
but there is a problem
a big problem without doubt every year
we seem to be seeing more and more young
people coming through with significant
knee injuries and primarily we're
talking about ACL ruptures the numbers
are staggering and extremely worrying
for every one person that was having an
ACL reconstruction in the late 90s
there's now 29 children
having those surgeries so the number of
injuries is without a doubt 29-fold yeah
evidence of a problem comes from
multiple sources other surgeons and
doctors are waving a warning flag we
increased by 29 folds amount of
operation devastating injuries that are
that that can cause complete change over
their life trajectory and early risk of
arthritis
people are committing to one or two
sports at most at the moment if they are
going to be part of the local community
and they they spend less time developing
other skills that would be naturally
developed when they are participating in
multiple Sports there on screens
sedentary and then suddenly they're in
very organized highly competitive Sports
environments there's
some evidence about you know sport
specialization so if you have a a child
who's very good at one sport they might
be pushed down that kind of route and
only play that sport probably second
biggest reason is that there is a huge
knowledge Gap in the UK about the
importance of injury prevention programs
and the importance of warming up kids
there's this myth in Grassroots sport
that kids don't get injured so they
don't need to warm up just you know get
off on the pitch and off you go it
couldn't be farther from the truth you
look at Australia you look at some of
the Scandinavian countries Netherlands
Canada all of them have started trying
to put together National programs to
deliver these warm-up programs and in
the UK that really hasn't happened it's
embarrassing to say that we're from the
UK we are so behind the rest of the
world female footballers are six times
more at risk of an ACL injury while
research and data is lacking young
female athletes across the board are
more susceptible to the injury than boys
and young men for 20 years we have known
that there's an increased ACL injury
rate in women and girls compared to men
and boys the anatomical side of things
is what makes it more likely to rupture
the actual rupture is identical whether
you're male or female it's been
overloaded what other factors impact
that ligament the obvious one to mention
first is there's a menstrual cycle and
that appears to have some impact on
injury there's a fluctuation of hormones
through the menstrual cycle it's just
not the full picture it contributes what
we don't yet understand there's a
nuanced gender issue there that just
needs a bit of exploring is it about
attitudes to girls being Physically
Active around that age is it
accessibility opportunity to to stay
Physically Active when they become
teenagers we don't fully understand that
yet society places more emphasis on
support for boys teenagers young men
than it does for Girls teenage girls
young women is that fair 100 there's no
doubt that there are gender biases out
there and and we need to break down
those barriers it would be correct to
say there has been some gender bias I do
think people are really starting to look
at this and trying to think how to
counteract it and making effort to
counteract it
alarming my legs straight and it snapped
inwards I heard a pop I actually done my
ACL twice sports like football and
netball can be harsh on female ACLs
the Sky News sports bulletin is brought
to you by vitality
foreign
breakfast coming up we'll join a park
run with thousands of people celebrating
75 years of the NHS
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello welcome back you're watching Sky
News break first it's time now to take a
look at the entertainment stories making
this week's backstage podcast
[Music]
hello and welcome to this the visual
edition of the backstage podcast with
all the latest interviews and news from
the world of TV and film I'm Katie
Spencer and I'm joined here by Sky's
entertainment reporter Claire Gregory
hello and also coming all the way from
New York it's Stevie Wong TV and film
reviewer
hello coming up on this week's show
[Applause]
that pipe squished me all out of shape
we got a dead body and a lot of people
to talk to what's your name
first up it's a bit of a family-friendly
offering from Pixar and Disney which
poses the question what would happen if
Fire and Water fell in love this is
directed by the same director who did
the good dinosaur and Cars 2 uh Peter's
son and Claire you were fortunate enough
to catch up with some of the cast on
this what did you think for starters
yeah it's I think this is really cute
it's kind of a cute story it's set in
element City where all your elements
live together so earth wind water fire
and as you say fire and water two of
them they fall in love and it's kind of
about that relationship but it's also a
look at immigration and director
Peterson's been very open about the fact
that it's sort of based on his own
relationship with his American Wife he's
Korean
um and it wasn't just Peter who had a
personal connection to the store either
when I caught up with Leah Lewis who
voices our main character Ember and
Mamadou athi who voices Wade the watery
man
um he talks about how it had a really
personal connection for him as well in
terms of the story of immigration I
became a citizen while we were making
this movie um I remember even before
like I did Jurassic here I was almost
not able to do it because of the covert
situation shut down like the immigration
officers and bull bar so I was like oh
my God this is crazy so doing this movie
while becoming a citizen while we're
like you know thinking about all the
journey that my family like took just to
get here just to well not here but in
the states to build a life it's been
it's been extremely moving and and my
parents they saw the movie of the
premiere
um and my dad had seen it like twice
since it's it's it means a lot to them
as well so it's so heartwarming to feel
that they care about it as just as
deeply as we do what did you think of
this Stevie do you think Pixar is really
doing enough to sort of change things up
up I guess between each film I think
weirdly the the movie looks like a
sequel to inside out and I think
immediately people are like oh what's
going on and then when you watch it it
actually has nothing to do with it or
maybe this in the kind of weirdly
Universe of but you know this movie has
had the worst box office opening in 28
years of Pixar so uh this is not faring
well for for future films that that they
have in line I don't know I think I
think movies and you know animation
films or family films in general are
kind of suffering this summer problem is
isn't it the Disney are fighting against
themselves so they're putting these big
movies out in cinemas but families are
looking at it and going oh actually uh
we don't know if we're gonna pay for
that when we can just wait a couple of
months and we know it'll come to Disney
plus so
um it's a it's a tricky one and I don't
see a natural resolution anytime soon
well look if you fancy watching
Elemental it's out now in cinemas how
about though we move on to some TV and a
bit of a who done it's coming to Apple
TV plus the return of the after party if
you didn't catch the last series that
series season one all centered around a
high school this time the season returns
with a different murder mystery based
around a wedding we should say you don't
need to of course season one do you to
enjoy this no not at all this is
completely Standalone and what's quite
fun about the after party both first
series and now this is each episode is
told from a different character's
perspective and each of those
perspectives has its own genre of the
idea being that it sort of matches up
with that character's personality so the
Knight is retold each episode and you
kind of get breadcrumbs along the way as
to the murder mystery so it's it's a
really kind of good fun way of telling
that story brilliant cast as well isn't
it Stevie that's one of the elements
that hooks you in with this oh yeah not
only is the original cast members
Tiffany haddish Sam Richardson and Zoe
Chow returning for the uh after party uh
this this season also has John Cho Paul
Walter Hauser kenjung and also a certain
Jack Whitehall
um we always have issue with his accent
and in this case apparently it's it's
still a problem is it just me I still
struggle to get my head around Jack
Whitehall being a natural actor and not
a comedian I mean it's a funny character
that he plays in this as well and
actually when when we spoke to him for
the podcast he said it's actually a good
one for him in terms of booking future
jobs he thinks it's also a great job for
your Show reel because there's so many
different little calling cards that you
can add into a Show reel having done
this and it's going to be great to send
it to our agent and say I want this out
to all of the directors in the period
drama space in the Heist movie space
yeah like this just shows that I can do
all of these genres to get this to Wes
Anderson let them know I'm a real actor
yeah yeah well it might might not be
sort of laugh out loud hugely funny but
it's entertaining enough I think is is
what we agree on next up though a bit of
a genre mashing one for you a
coming-of-age story mixed in with a bit
of a gangster tale it's uh coming out on
sky and it's called then you run so this
is an eight-part drama based on a novel
called you and it follows four
rebellious teenagers from London they're
sweary it's um by A Series of
Unfortunate Events they end up in
Rotterdam and think it's it's a very bad
summer holidays they have on is this
does that sum it up correctly do we
think yeah they're trying to have the
holiday of their teenage dreams and it
ends up being something of a road trip
as they try to escape the danger they've
got themselves into it it really is
quite a dangerous situation but one of
the things I really love about this is
these teenagers are not written in a way
that is kind of very stereotyping cliche
and actually often we see teenagers on
screen they're not remotely realistic to
kind of what grown-ups think teenagers
like whereas these guys very much um
they seem very authentic and it's all
about the Chemistry Between the the lead
actors isn't it Stevie oh yeah totally
and what a good cast Leah McNamara who
you might remember was a normal people
uh Vivian Opera who was in rylane a
couple months ago and she was the lead
in that and she was so wonderful and so
nice to see her on this screen Jasmine
Monet prince who was in Hannah in a show
that we all liked and a newcomer named
is Adora fairhurst and so the the fact
that this these four uh young ladies are
so good together as friends and they're
very believable
um is is really the whole point uh of
this show and and it's just you know I
know you talked to them Claire recently
um about the series yeah when I caught
up with Leah and Yasmin I had to kind of
ask about this idea that you know quite
often teenagers they are sort of
overlooked or maybe underestimated when
it comes to their on-screen portrayals
as soon as I read the script it was so
natural and that's what drew me to it
just the banter between them especially
the fact that as girls they were just
cursing each other around you're like
yes this is normal this is what they do
especially when you're close to people
you don't really be sweet with one
another you just told them the truth for
you just kind of annoy them so I think
that's what really drew me too girls are
not like these perfectly Poise just like
I always looking lovely and like always
speaking so one and like like you know
braiding each other's hair and sitting
around and like having pillow fights and
just like girly things like I love how
they're almost like the antithesis of
that and but that is like Womanhood and
that's like you know being a teenager
and like being with your friends like
you're always slagging each other like
you're always having fun and I I also
kind of like I like how in my mind
they're kind of like the outcasts like
within their school but like they don't
want like but they're fine with that
like they are such a close-knit and I
feel like all their personalities are so
different that they all just bounce like
I think we all and we all bounce off
each other but the characters are all so
different and I feel like there's an
element in each person and someone's
like oh like oh I'm like Ruth like and
now way or like oh I have a friend
that's like you know so like saying
whatever it is so yeah I loved when I
read them it's a brilliant cast but also
just visually it's so well done and it
just has something there's something
about it that is just very edgy and cool
and different and I don't think it's
kind of weird original yeah original
yeah there's really nothing out there
right now that looks like this that
feels like this that has the kind of I
mean the the situations is pretty life
and death at this you know and yet it's
it's it's light-hearted and funny and
twisted at the same time and it's all
these wonderful things the thing about
this as well is when you start watching
it we've already said uh that it's got
the gangster element it's got the coming
of age thing it's also scandi Noir as
well because those first few minutes of
this it's uh of each episode actually
it's all in subtitles as well which
completely three years didn't it Stevie
because we were like you have to watch
this coming of age gangster thing you're
like wow what I think we are all in
agreement though that that is the one to
look at this week pick of the week kick
of the week very unusual and that's out
now on Skymax and you can also stream it
on now TV look if you have enjoyed
watching this the visual edition of
Backstage well don't forget we have
longer extended interviews on the
podcast itself with uh many of the stars
from The After Party Elemental and then
you run all you need to do is scan the
QR code which is on your screen now or
you can just look up Sky's backstage
wherever you usually get your podcast
from that's it for us for this week
thank you Claire thank you Stephen
thank you and we will see you again very
soon
thanks very much indeed to all of them
now then NHS staff and volunteers as
well as local communities are taking
part in park runs across the UK today to
help the Health Service celebrate its
75th Anniversary well skies at Bethlehem
Royal Hospital in South London and I
hope you got your running shoes on
Malena
no I failed miserabiana I'm wearing a
dress so clearly I won't be doing any
running but it's the NHS staff and
volunteers getting ready to go here
behind me it's not ideal running weather
it's a little bit hot a little bit humid
it's overcast at least but they say
they're ready they're about to start
their 5K run and last time an event like
this was held for the NHS 70th
Anniversary nearly 150 000 people across
the country took part and the organizers
hope they'll be able to match that this
year as well for that Milestone
anniversary and what they say what they
want to do really is to promote that
link between physical exercise and good
mental health especially poignant
because we're here on the grounds of a
psychiatric hospital and it is also one
of the only two NHS grounds that are
hosting the park run this year now to
join me talk a little bit more about
this we've got Jackie and Lee who is
consultant clinical psychologist now
Jackie do you want to tell me a little
bit about why getting out and about
getting enough physical exercise why is
that good for mental health
well it's really important for all of us
to think about our well-being and we're
increasingly understanding that good
diet exercise is really important and
park run isn't just about the running
it's also about the volunteering it's
about getting involved it's a very
sociable event and you know it's really
something that encourages people to get
out of bed on a Saturday morning and
come down meet up with some friends and
have a really friendly
opportunity to have a run to you know
get involved in something it's a really
very sociable thing so all of those
things put together are really good for
our mental health and so how did you
prepare for your run today it's not
exactly the ideal running conditions is
it well I guess it's just a routine for
me now so you know I used to run longer
distances but now as I'm getting older
this is a really good distance and as I
say a really good thing to sort of
motivate you to get up on a Saturday
morning and do something to sort of come
down and be with other Runners other
friends and we also have people walking
so it's not just running so you can come
and walk you can volunteer you know you
can really get involved in something
that's quite exciting thank you so much
Jackie so you can see lots of uh people
are getting ready to go gearing up I
won't be with them but I'll be here
cheering on them
okay we'll let you off from Elena just
this once
take a look now what the weather's doing
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well thunderstorms will push across
Britain and Ireland today giving some
torrential downpours and possibly
causing some disruption this morning
will be hot and humid for Central and
Eastern Parts but some of us are already
seeing some showers this morning those
showers will intensify as they push
Northeast
the Met Office a warning that the
torrential rain and Gusty winds could
cause some disruption East Anglia should
remain largely dry until the afternoon
and temperatures could hit 33 degrees
that would make it the hottest day of
the year so far
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
coming up we'll take a look at this
morning's papers with International
marketing Partners chief executive
Allison Stewart Allen and uh PR and
crisis management expert Kevin Craig
that's coming up next
[Music]
uh I think octopuses are fascinating in
a number of different ways probably one
of the things that's interesting about
them is they're sort of considered in
some ways an honorary vertebrate in the
sense that they're closely related to
the other mollusks which are snails and
slugs but they're very fast in their
behavior and they act a little bit
um like many of the vertebrates do and
we sort of have this pride of place as
vertebrates ourselves and so they're
very interesting but distantly related
animal to us they're similar to humans
in many ways because all animals are we
have very common things that run very
deep in uh evolutionary history amongst
the animals and so you know we all
um we all need food we all fear
predators and look for shelter we all
need to find mates for the most part so
there's some very deep animal
commonalities but there's been some
recent work uh in outside of my field
but related to octopuses that have shown
that they're um they're some of their
brain functions some of their genetics
uh are doing things that are very
similar to what uh what we do uh
octopuses use this um this reaching
behavior in a number of different ways
and one of the ways that they uh use
this behavior is to sort of reach out
and investigate or sometimes discourage
um to discourage other animals that are
investigating the food the octopus is
working on and so
um you know I wasn't involved in that
study
um but but that's that's generally
what's going on I made a documentary
with uh PBS here in the United States
and BBC uh over your way that uh in BBC
I always believe it was called
um the octopus in my uh living room and
uh it's an exploration of of octopuses
but from a particular point of view that
that I found interesting which is how do
they relate to other animals they're
they're famously solitary and yet you
know we uh I kept an octopus in the
house and my daughter and I took care of
her and um you know she really seemed to
to uh be very engaged in interacting
with us and it raises some interesting
questions to me about why is this
solitary animal also so skilled at
interacting with other beings
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll try now for our final delve into
the papers this morning here with me is
Alison Stewart Allen chief executive of
international marketing partners and
Kevin Craig PR and crisis management
experts so welcome back once again and
we're going deep into the papers now
we're going to the telegraph this is
page 13 the Telegraph and it's how a
brand of uh shoe or style of shoe lots
of imitators absolutely that's uh really
um taken off again Yes again so this is
about Birkenstocks so this is a brand
that's over 250 years old I suspect
people don't know that it was a no I
didn't know that yeah so late 1700s
probably about that old
well what's so interesting is how this
this company has stayed current first
off uh it's owned Now by private Equity
company who are looking at making uh
taking uh Birkenstocks public selling
shares it would be 4.7 billion pounds in
value if it does go on the market
one of the things about this brand is
its collaboration with designers so
while normally you can expect to pick up
a pair for under 100 pounds now there is
a pair that's 870 pounds because it's a
collaboration with Christian Dior so
there's all of these interesting
permutations on the theme I think what's
interesting is you know back in the 60s
Birkenstock was the shoe of protest
really it was the ugly shoe and you
would wear it because you were making a
statement and now it's not much less
ugly but it's branding interestingly is
what makes it covetable these days and
during covid people went online you know
we went on a lot of walks uh so trainers
shoes like this were really popular and
they have stayed popular now comfortable
the way but but as I say so many
imitations out there incredible
different brands who are doing the same
Styles yes absolutely so Kevin take us
to um the mirror next because there's a
story about a particular EasyJet flight
yes and it's again it's the other side
of the the Spectrum in terms of a
negative Brand Story uh the and it's in
the mirror but it's also elsewhere
across the papers today the headline is
not so easy yet and you know this is a
cautionary tale for travelers because
what happened was a a plane from uh
Lanzarote to Liverpool easy to let
everybody on and only after that did
they then say that because of the wind
conditions it's not like nobody knows
that Lanzarote is not windy but anyway
putting that to one side they then
realized subsequently that they wanted
17 passengers to get off because the
plane was too heavy now in the papers
stories like this really resonate
because it comes off the back of the
fact that EasyJet as which covered last
week has got double the number of
canceled flights compared to jet2 and
Ryanair and over half the people who
have a problem with EasyJet say that
there's no one there to help you and why
this story resonated with me is that
last summer EasyJet dumped me and my
family in Rose airport at three in the
morning and I'm over it absolutely fine
but this story is a is is interesting
because it strikes a chord and they've
they've got to be careful well yes and
yet I guess you're horrendous I'm sorry
for you for it some people will say well
I say anything happened to me with a
different Airline but
um but um and EasyJet themselves do
acknowledge that 19 passengers were
asked to come off because of weight
limits in in those weather conditions
and and they say it was for safety
reasons essentially and the volunteers
were provided with with compensation so
that's what easy Justice well indeed and
you know talk talking to somebody is CEO
PLM I recognize corporate PR when I hear
it yeah yeah okay
let's move on to the story that we
didn't get to in the last hour we teased
everybody about yeah it's a cracking
story it is a cracking story it is such
a lovely heartwarming story so it's
about an author and this man uh in his
50s has written a young adult uh
category title of a book about ghosts
and teenagers uh and he's in a Bookshop
in Fort Worth Texas at a table as you
are I mean I'm an author and I had the
same book signing you have a book
signing and he's there for the book
signing uh waiting for people to come up
enthusiastic I just paid for my book
please sign it anyway nobody came up to
this poor man so a couple of people in
the shop young young guys who are on
Tick Tock said you know we really feel
for you we're going to do a little Tick
Tock video with you is that all right
and he said sure that would be nice so
they do this little Tick Tock and he
video and he talks about the book anyway
these two guys upload this video to tick
tock about this poor author having
nobody visiting
18 million hits and now his book is at
the top of the young adult category on
Amazon and he said in this piece uh you
know he's living the dream he always
wanted to be an author he was told
you'll never make a living at it he
thought well I'm still going to pursue
it and because of this Tick Tock video
now he is a made author he's now
successful power of marketing exactly to
the white people absolutely youth Market
absolutely but it also shows you the
scale of social media and its reach uh
as a platform and its influence it
didn't know the boys did he no okay no
no those are very sophisticated
absolutely no no these are just a couple
of Shoppers in the bookstore
extraordinary Services
yeah that's great that's great to hear
yeah I bet his book signings aren't so
um not now
take us onto the times um Kevin a story
about lse's Chief I'm assuming this
isn't the London School of Economics no
no it's the um it's the London Stock
Exchange and yeah for me as a you know
we've got two business people on this
morning but as the founder of a uh of a
multi-million pound business and one you
know we have looked at listing um as a
potential option for the future but
what's really striking about this story
here is that the head of the London
Stock Exchange has warned that you know
she wants the political class to be
worried about the fact that if you're a
UK founded company inevitably now it's
more likely when you get to a certain
point you list overseas and that didn't
used to be the case in in in in in in
the UK and it and it's worrying because
you know it matters where Capital
markets move and where investment
follows and if we we are want to be
proud of British business we want
companies to list here uh and you know I
just think it's you know last year there
were you know two of the only four
technology companies in the ftse 100
were delisted and we need to create the
economic conditions to have more
listings in London and if you know it's
important to have them in this country
well because
um the investors will the capital will
stay in in this country there's a whole
um sideline of con other Industries the
financial PR the knock-on investment
that follows if the if they list on our
market and it's just very good for us is
to say that Britain is open for business
so hopefully that she'll get listened to
okay interesting stuff and finally let's
quickly take a look at the times and a
story about uh voice checks to protect
children yes absolutely really really
interesting so what's going on basically
is there's Tech to be able to to
determine the age of a pla a user of a
website based on their voice and there
are two companies a Swiss company and a
British company that have this
technology and one of the idea deals is
that this technology is used to screen
and remove those that are under 18 from
visiting porn sites and gambling and
alcohol sites so we're out of time but
interesting that technology can be
harmful to children but may potentially
protect them as well absolutely anyway
lovely to see you both this morning
thanks so much for coming in thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello it's nine o'clock you're watching
Sky News breakfast these are our top
stories here this morning insensitive
and unacceptable a grieving mother says
she's appalled by Top Gun style tweets
posted by Kent Police hours after her
daughter was found dead
what is the mindset of people
investigating crimes on our behalf what
is their mindset
school girl killed after a car crashed
into her school in Wimbledon is named as
eight-year-old Selena Lau
police investigations are continuing
here as a community remains deeply
shocked by an accident which killed
Selena
the U.S is to provide Ukraine with
highly controversial cluster bombs
saying it will not leave the country
defenseless
and I am at Bethlehem Royal Hospital in
South London one of thousands of places
across the country where people will be
taking part in a park run to celebrate
75 years of the NHS
[Applause]
Andy Murray says he'll see if he still
has the motivation to play at Wimbledon
again after going out in the second
round
and it's a crucial day a third day of
the ashes test it's a must win test for
England and they need quick wickets
is
[Music]
and I'll be speaking to the friend of
the late Deborah James who's released a
charity single in her memory
[Music]
hello very good morning and welcome to
Sky News breakfast
can police have been accused of posting
insensitive and unacceptable tweets
surrounding the death of a 21 year old
woman azra Kamal died after falling from
a dual carriageway bridge and within
hours the police posted congratulatory
messages about their investigation using
a scene from the film Top Gun her
mother's told Sky News the Tweet was
horrendous Jason Farrell has this report
below the Medway viaduct in Kent Nettles
have reclaimed a shrine left in the
memory of azra Kamal
the 21 year old died here in July 2020
falling from the jewel carriageway
Bridge after her car broke down and
caught fire she was traveling back to
London with a male friend
paramedics had tried in vain to save
azero police were called to the scene
but azra's family were recently shocked
to discover what the police had tweeted
in the immediate wake of that
investigation
Kent crime scene investigators
congratulate themselves on the speed of
their work using a gif from the movie
Top Gun characters Maverick and Goose
high five the words great teamwork as
they celebrate identifying the deceased
person within 90 minutes of being at the
scene
this is azra's Mother nevras
that tweet was just horrendous I could
not really could not believe that
professional police officers would
high-five themselves and Pat themselves
on the back on the back of my daughter's
demise it's more than insensitive it's
unacceptable that they think that they
can still the forensic team in Kent
think that that's acceptable what is the
mindset of people investigating crimes
on our behalf what is their mindset
another tweet celebrates the police
drone work with the hashtag cracking bit
of Kit and another reports within hours
that the police are satisfied there are
no suspicious circumstances even though
Ezra's mother is being told they're
still investigating
the initial suspect the man azra was
traveling with said that in the darkness
azra had not seen the drop as she
climbed over the central reservation
barrier he was released and the
investigation closed before the end of
the first day
it strikes me that a murder
investigation being open and closed
within 24 hours is not an adequate
investigation I think it's shocking that
with an investigation ongoing and in
fact within a few hours of of Never as
having been informed of her daughter's
death the police would brag about the
expediency of the investigation or the
impressiveness of their kids
ten police could have conducted what's
called a forensic post-mortem to look
for Clues as to whether anything
physical had happened to azra before she
fell but they instead did a standard
post-mortem deciding that what happened
here was not suspicious
an independent review of azra's Case by
Essex police suggested a forensic level
postmortem would have helped avoid
unanswered questions by being able to
negate any third-party involvement and
that it may have been prudent to release
the suspect under investigation rather
than close the case
do the job that you're supposed to do
look at the information look at the
leads
look at the timelines look at the
interviews go back to the witnesses yeah
because no one saw Ezra die
in question to Ezra's death returned a
verdict of misadventure Kent Police says
their investigation was full and
thorough and officers determined there
were no suspicious circumstances the
investigation by Essex police concluded
the service provided by Kent Police had
been acceptable
the independent office for police
conduct made the same conclusion
although that decision was appealed and
has been reopened the Tweet has been
removed and the complaint is being
reviewed by an independent police force
the family think this image reflects the
way things were investigated
Jason Farrell Sky News
the eight-year-old girl who died after a
Land Rover crashed into the grounds of
her primary school in Wimbledon has been
named as Selena Lao a correspondent
Alice Porter is in Wimbledon Forest this
morning and Alice saw this little girl
named last night of photographs released
to further personalizing this tragedy
that's right and we actually heard a
statement from the family yesterday who
described Selena as an intelligent and
cheeky girl adored and loved by everyone
and I think that's been very much the
feeling here outside the school in
Wimbledon today there's been as the
morning's gone on a steady stream of
people coming to lay flowers down in
front of the school but many have just
stood in absolute shock and horror at
what took place two days ago I think one
of the particularly sad notes that I've
seen outside the school Gates is notes
written clearly by children potentially
contemporaries of Selena saying I will
miss you which I think to see that in
children's writing really brings home
the message this was a little
eight-year-old girl who was enjoying the
end of time there was a tea party in the
garden celebrating the end of term when
quite suddenly and quite violently a
Land Rover came through the barriers
behind me and made its way through where
the children were gathered and one can
only imagine the horror it must have
been for the children and teachers who
were there at the time now we know
another eight-year-old girl is in
hospital in a critical condition as well
as a 40 year old woman and I think it's
important to stress how many people
would were injured in the accident there
were 16 people treated at the scene and
12 were taken to hospital for further
treatment I think questions really
remain exactly what happened on Thursday
which led the Land Rover to make its way
through the barrier behind me and cause
such Devastation and now the
Metropolitan Police say a local woman
from Wimbledon who's 46 years old has
been arrested on suspicion of causing
death by dangerous driving she has been
released on bail pending a police
investigation but I think here in the
local community there was just a sense
of everyone reeling from what happened
this is very quiet area of Southwest
London the golf club in front of me held
a minute silence yesterday in Mark of I
think really it is a sense here of
confusion but also some anger as well
I've had one man come up to me and say
that this road along here how dangerous
it is and saying that it should have
always been one way we don't know the
full extent of what happened at all but
I think there are more and more
questions of being asked of what's
happened on Thursday which unfortunately
killed a little eight-year-old girl
Alice thanks very much indeed
Pentagon has confirmed the U.S will send
cluster bombs to Ukraine as part of a
new military aid package Ukraine has
been asking for the weapons for months
the explosives are believed to pose a
high risk to civilians more than 100
countries have banned cluster Munitions
partly because the explosive bomblets
can remain undetonated in civilian areas
but the U.S national security adviser
Jake Sullivan said the U.S won't leave
Ukraine defenseless
we have provided Ukraine with a historic
amount of unitary artillery rounds and
we are ramping up domestic production of
these rounds we've already seen
substantial increases in production but
this process will continue to take time
and it will be critical to provide
Ukraine with a bridge of supplies while
our domestic production is ramped up we
will not leave Ukraine defenseless at
any point in this conflict period
what is our U.S correspondent Mark Stone
well President Biden said last night
that this decision was not easy and I
think that's a clear acceptance of just
how controversial the decision is
cluster Munitions are banned by most
countries around the world most of
America's NATO partner countries have
signed a convention Banning the use or
transfer of cluster bombs to other
countries the reason simply is because
of their indiscriminate Legacy the bombs
detonate above a Target Distributing
hundreds of smaller bomblets over a wide
area a proportion of them don't explode
and in past Wars they have killed mostly
civilians long after the wars have come
to an end worldwide it's estimated that
97 of cluster munition casualties are
civilians so why is America sending them
to Ukraine well I think it's a clear
indication that the war is not going
well for Ukraine the spring offensive
hasn't had the desired impact more
conventional artillery stocks are
running low and so the cluster bombs Act
as a bridge Supply until more
Conventional Weapons can be produced and
they would also have a big impact on the
battlefield wiping out dug in Russian
troops the Americans also argue that
their cluster Munitions are more
sophisticated than those the Russians
are already using on the battlefield
leaving fewer unexploded and they say
that on balance the Legacy risk to
civilians down the line from their bombs
is less than the risk to civilians now
from the Russian attacks still it is a
risky strategy it smacks of a war not
going well and some will argue that it
erodes America's claim to the moral High
Ground
regard to General Lord Richard Danner is
the former Chief of the general staff of
the British army a very good morning to
you thanks so much for talking to us
what do you make of the US decision to
send cluster bombs to Ukraine have they
done the right thing do you think
well as Joe Biden said I think it's a
very difficult decision and it's very
difficult to have a sort of unitary
opinion about it
um our country along with many others
have banned cluster weapons from
personal experience when I was commander
British forces we went into Kosovo in
1999 the only two soldiers that we lost
were as a result of unexploded Munitions
from NATO cluster weapons which at that
stage we're still allowed to be used I
think the other issue is one of timing I
can understand why the Americans want to
provide this additional Firepower to
Ukraine to help its counter-offensive
along but as we're coming up with the
Vilnius NATO Summit where one of the
most important things is that we show
the unity of NATO together I think to
have announced deployment of these
weapons at this moment when so many
other NATO countries have banned them
runs the risk of having a conversation
just as such as we're having now about
whether this is a good idea whether it's
the right idea and it runs the risk of
fracturing to an extent but NATO Harmony
but as Joe Biden said and I've just said
it's a difficult decision I think on
balance it's probably the right thing to
do but I'm not alone in being deeply
uncomfortable about having to go to this
measure just because the ukrainians are
running out of ammunition and the
Americans and ourselves have not been
able to ramp up our own Industrial
Supply quick enough to be able to
provide the ukrainians with the more
conventional type of Weaponry that they
have been using and we've been gifting
them up to now
well yes and these Munitions are
contentious because they're deemed so
high risk for civilians so do you think
that the US does lose its high moral
ground by sending them
well you have to think about it um this
war is being fought on Ukrainian
territory quite obviously because the
ukrainians want to throw the Russians
off their territory so it means that
these weapons will be used against
Russian soldiers who are dug in on
Ukrainian territory now we know that
there is a proportion of the
submunitions that don't detonate uh on
Landing now Americans say it's only
three percent uh of theirs uh other
other nations the Russians we criticize
their use of cluster weapons and say it
can be between 30 and 40 percent that
don't go off the point being is that we
are by Design scattering across part of
Ukraine weapons which we know will not
all go off and that there will be more
unexploded ordinance lying around or
parts of Ukraine for many years to come
that takes quite a lot of getting ahead
round
um personally I'm disappointed that we
haven't been able to provide quick
enough all the equipment and ammunition
that Ukraine needs to be able to conduct
this counter-offensive more quickly and
better because we know it's really
important that Ukraine does succeed and
succeed this year so this is a force
measure that divides opinion it's
unfortunate as I said I think the timing
is particularly unfortunate are you
concerned then that the
counter-offensive is going too slowly
and do you think the fact that these
weapons are being sent is a sign of that
um can I check the first part of that
question of first
um it is going slowly but I don't think
we can criticize and Norway should we
criticize the ukrainians for going
slowly uh while we have been training
Ukrainian soldiers uh eventually taking
decisions to provide them with more and
better and more sophisticated largely
Western Equipment the Russians have
spent the same time over the last winter
and this spring uh developing really
deep and complicated defensive positions
now the ukrainians don't want to throw
their young men's lives onto those
prepared defensive positions needlessly
or recklessly in the same way that the
Russians frankly were throwing their
young men at Ukrainian defensive
positions last year so the ukrainians
are going cautiously they're going
carefully they are looking to probe
along the extensive Russian defensive
lines to find weaker points and when
they have found one or two or more
weaker points that's when I think we
will see their attack brigades largely
equipped with Western Equipment um that
they've been preparing we've been
helping with in recent months we'll see
them deployed trying to break in and
break through the Russian positions and
if they're able to do that and are able
to break out Beyond this could then
change the whole nature of the war very
favorably in the ukrainian's favor
uh you mentioned the NATO Gathering next
week
um the UK is pushing for Ukraine to have
its membership of NATO fast tracked
there are reports today that the U.S
could back the UK on that is that
something that you would welcome
well there's no doubt in my mind that
Ukraine should join NATO at some point
and probably at not too much in the
distant future but I think it's it's
very difficult for uh Nate for Ukraine
to join NATO while this is still a hot
war with Russia because if that does
happen then almost by reverse
engineering Article 5 it would actually
bring all the other NATO member nations
into the war that's currently ongoing in
Ukraine against Russia so I think what
we should do is do all that we can to
help Ukraine conclude this war and as
soon as that is done we should then
invite Nate uh we should then invite
Ukraine to join NATO but Vilnius in the
next few days they need to be shown a
clear path at the end of that path is an
invitation to join NATO but I think
reasonable people would accept that it
would be foolhardy and playing into the
Russians propaganda if we were to to
invite Ukraine to join NATO while the
war is still hot because the Russians
could then say even more loudly than
they are saying now well this war isn't
just against Ukraine this is now the
whole West the whole of NATO fighting
Russia and that if anything was going to
unite the Russian people against the
West I think that would so we need to be
cautious but also encourage Ukraine that
there is light at the end of the tunnel
that tunnel is only as long as this war
remains hot
General lowdana we appreciate your time
this morning and your thoughts thanks
very much indeed thanks Adam
now is on the stories other stories
making the news this morning and it's
been reported that a well-known BBC
presenter has been taken off air over
claims of payments being made to a
teenager in exchange for sexually
explicit images the BBC says it takes
any allegations very seriously following
reports in the Sun newspaper that the
presenter had been accused of paying the
teenager more than 35
000 pounds for sexual pictures starting
when they were 17.
the Dutch prime minister Mark Rutter has
resigned following the collapse of his
four-party coalition government the
prime minister announced that the
differences between the Coalition
Partners over migration policy were
irreconcilable he'll remain in office in
a caretaker capacity until a new ruling
Coalition is chosen
the former Manchester United goalkeeper
Edwin van de SAR is in intensive care
after suffering a bleed around his brain
the 52 year old who stepped down as
iax's chief executive earlier this year
is said to be in a stable condition
an ancient Marble Head has been
Unearthed by construction workers in the
historic Center of Rome the city mayor
shared pictures of The Relic on Twitter
writing Roma continues to return
precious evidence of its past
carved in Greek marble it's thought to
belong to a statue of a female goddess
it's a pretty wild weather around this
weekend let's get the details
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well thunderstorms will push across
Britain and Ireland today giving some
torrential downpours and possibly
causing some disruption too this morning
will be hot and humid for Central and
Eastern Parts but some of us are already
seeing some showers this morning those
showers will intensify as they push
Northeast
the Met Office a warning that the
torrential rain and Gusty winds could
cause some disruption East Anglia should
remain largely dry until the afternoon
and temperatures could hit 33 degrees
making it the hottest day of the year so
far
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
still to come we got all the sport with
Jackie who's at Wimbledon and Jackie not
a great day yesterday at Wimbledon
no it was a really really bad day for
the British Men Yesterday at Wimbledon
largely disappointing well largely very
disappointing we'll look at Andy
Murray's future he cast a few doubts
over that in his press conference after
losing again in the second round here
looking at the bits and pieces of
Wimbledon yesterday as well also what
about the ashes day three today of the
Third
Ash's test match it's one that England
have to win England need quick wickets
despite heroics from Ben Stokes
yesterday
and Lewis Hamilton is hoping for huge
improvements ahead of qualifying for the
British Grand Prix
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
they pushed the protesters further back
here there's around two or three hundred
still remaining
I'm Dan Whitehead and I'm Sky news's
West of England correspondent
this fan goes onto the streets of
Plymouth seven days a week 365 days a
year these facilities at the moment are
a lifesaver
[Music]
from fishing communities to bustling
cities we spend every day reporting from
across the region hearing from people
who have real stories
I'm gonna have nowhere to live for
three or four months
there are still people inside the
properties here
they are coming from the epicenter of
what is now a global Health pandemic
we were seeing and speaking to young
women who were selling themselves right
on the High Street it was desperately
sad and the fact it was happening right
in the hearts of this community
before brexit these oysters were being
exported to the EU but the train stopped
overnight
what's your feeling about the future
there Blakely quite OB
V finished I don't know
so it was a bad day for the British
players at Wimbledon with an emotional
Andy Murray hinting that he may have
played his last match at the tournament
so let's go back to Jackie beltrail at
Wimbledon and a lot of people would be
very disappointed if Andy Murray isn't
bad but a really sad day for him
yesterday
it was so sad watching him touch up the
hill back to his I'm assuming his rental
flat near here all alone just a very
desolate looking tired figure and yeah
doubts in the press conference about
whether he had the motivation to carry
on and do this again he does seem to
work extremely hard and he is just not
getting the rewards at the very high
level If he if he finished that match
um when it started under the roof at
night on Center Court the day before
yesterday you feel that he perhaps had
the ascendancy and would have won it
but it's spilled over into day two it
wasn't quite the same atmosphere he
wasn't quite the same at the end he was
asked how many wimbledon's he had left
he said this
I don't know to be honest I'm obviously
very disappointed just now
um
yeah obviously you never know how many
opportunities you're going to get to
play here
so I'm now joined by Dom inglotz who was
a very close teammate of Andy Murray
when they won the Davis Cup uh all those
years ago it's not many years ago but it
feels a long time ago now and Dom we've
just been hearing from andina's press
conference and he just sounded so
despondent and disappointed I'm sorry to
make you stand there in the rain but do
you think that was just him talking In
the Heat of the Moment that he just lost
or do you think he is really thinking I
don't know how many more times I can do
this in losing the second round I think
every single player wants to take a huge
loss like that and I mean really
gut-wrenching they think the worst it's
natural and I think he needs a day maybe
two to really get over it and then
reassess but honestly don't rule out
Andy Murray he loves competing he loves
being out there he does not want to end
his Wimbledon run like that I think he's
got one more in him I really hope he
does um and he you know we see him
better and better every single week his
his Fitness is getting there so I think
next year he could be even better
potentially than he is right now but he
he was better than he was last year but
he still managed to go out in the second
round is that because he's drawn he's
had a bit of an unlucky draw here he's
got sitsu past who suddenly when he came
here has become inspired and is barely
making an error you know what I think he
got very unlucky in the sense that yes
to to pass baby was not in the best form
but a good win against Dominic team in
five sets that's a confidence booster
then the fact that it went the drain
delay gave him an extra day to recover
after five sets freshened him up and
lastly Andy's a guy who starts a little
slow but then builds up we've seen so
many results where he wins in three sets
or five sets I think if he'd had that
extra pardon me time on the Center Court
I think he would have won that match so
a few things going against him you know
you have to take that into consideration
I think he'll be back I redo yeah but
the fact he's 36 and the other fellow
was 24 probably has a little bit to do
with it as well and really disappointing
result yesterday apart from Andy was cam
Nori's result he was almost like well it
is a sure thing to get to the second
week it was a semi-finalist last year
why wouldn't he and yet that was so
disappointing to go out to Chris Eubanks
he's got to be gutted too I hear it will
be hundred percent gutted and I think
there's that expectation now once you've
been a semi-finalist that as you said
rightly making the second week is
automatic but I actually commentated
that match and Chris Eubanks was playing
off his off the charts I mean he was
hitting winners from everywhere Aces
Galore honestly cam Nori was doing
everything he could but this guy was
just playing like a man possessed so I
think kaminari can look back at it and
go okay it was unfortunate but you can't
sometimes face guys like that who just
do nothing wrong that day yeah they just
play Lights Out tennis Liam Brody has
had a great Wimbledon even though he
lost yesterday but he did best out of
everyone he got to the third round he's
going to walk away with his head held
really high isn't he absolutely I think
he's gonna feel so much confidence he
beat Paul garuna you know number four
seed this guy has been in the three of
the last five slams finals so to beat
someone like just shows that he's
capable of those wins very close match
against chapavalov he was up a break in
the third as well so very small
differences and I think going into the
new hardcore season coming up now in
America I think he'll feel very good
about his chances great boost to the
ranking great boost to the coffers as
well yeah and he was very fun his
interviews were the best out of
everybody so we're out of time actually
done but just in a yes or a no I mean
how well is Katie Bolton going to do
today that's not yes or no question but
you know what I mean I think she could
do really well it's a very tough match
for a bikini really informed obviously
the defending Champion but let's not
rule her out I honestly really bad Casey
Bolton she's a great player she's got to
believe it just gotta believe it Dom
very much and did
if he's going on at Wimbledon a little
bit of a sort of a downer yes today but
plenty of other things going on in the
sport that were pretty exciting
yesterday let's have a look
the Sky News sports person is brought to
you by vitality
getting more people more active live
life with vitality
every week across the UK 85 percent of
school-age students take part in
approximately an hour of sport a week
organized Grassroots sport has lower
numbers but it translates to millions of
girls and boys between the age of 7 and
20 playing sport
but there is a problem
a big problem without doubt every year
we seem to be seeing more and more young
people coming through with significant
knee injuries and primarily we're
talking about ACL ruptures the numbers
are staggering and extremely worrying
for every one person that was having an
ACL reconstruction in the late 90s
there's now 29 children
having those surgeries so the number of
injuries is without a doubt 29-fold yeah
evidence of a problem comes from
multiple sources other surgeons and
doctors are waving a warning flag we
increase by 29 folds amount of operation
devastating injuries that are that that
can cause complete change of their life
trajectory and early risk of arthritis
people are committing to one or two
sports at most at the moment if they are
going to be part of the local community
and they they spend less time developing
other skills that would be naturally
developed when they are participating in
multiple Sports there on screens
sedentary and then suddenly they're in
very organized highly competitive Sports
environments there's
some evidence about you know sport
specialization so if you have a a child
who's very good at one sport they might
be pushed down that kind of route and
only play that sport probably second
biggest reason is that there is a huge
knowledge Gap in the UK about the
importance of injury prevention programs
and the importance of warming up kids
there's this myth in Grassroots sport
that kids don't get injured so they
don't need to warm up just you know get
off on the pitch and off you go it
couldn't be farther from the truth you
look at Australia you look at some of
the Scandinavian countries Netherlands
Canada all of them have started trying
to put together National programs to
deliver these warm-up programs and in
the UK that really hasn't happened it's
embarrassing to say that we're from the
UK we are so behind the rest of the
world female footballers are six times
more at risk of an ACL injury while
research and data is lacking young
female athletes across the board are
more susceptible to the injury than boys
and young men for 20 years we have known
that there's an increased ACL injury
rate in women and girls compared to men
and boys the anatomical side of things
is what makes it more likely to rupture
the actual rupture is identical whether
you're male or female it's been
overloaded what other factors impact
that ligament the obvious one to mention
first is there's a menstrual cycle
um and that appears to have some impact
on injury
um there's a fluctuation of hormones
through the menstrual cycle it's just
not the full picture it contributes but
we don't yet understand there's a
nuanced gender issue there that just
needs a bit of exploring is it about
attitudes to girls
um being Physically Active around that
age is it accessibility opportunity to
to stay Physically Active when they
become teenagers we don't fully
understand that yet society places more
emphasis on support for boys teenagers
young men than it does for Girls teenage
girls young women is that fair 100
there's no doubt that there are gender
biases out there and and we need to
break down those barriers it would be
correct to say there has been some
gender bias I do think people are really
starting to look at this and trying to
think how to counteract it and making
effort to counteract it
alarming my legs straight and it snapped
inwards I heard a pop I actually done my
ACL twice sports like
the Sky News sports bulletin is brought
to you by vitality
it's breakfast
Lots coming up here on Sky News
breakfast coming up we'll join a park
run with thousands of people celebrating
75 years of the NHS
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
staff and volunteers as well as local
communities are taking part in park runs
across the UK today to help the Health
Service celebrate its 75th Anniversary
well Skies Milena vaselinovich is at
Bethlehem Royal Hospital in South London
for us so talk us through it Malena that
they set off a little while ago didn't
they
they did indeed they are currently
coming back from their park run over
here after their 5K you see NHS staff
and volunteers sort of filtering through
the grounds of this hospital this is
actually one of only two NHS sites which
are hosting this park run this year and
last year for the 70th Anniversary when
this kind of event was held nearly 140
000 people took part across the country
so this is just one of many many Park
crowns that are happening at the moment
so they're coming over here because
they're doing pretty good time because
they only set off about half an hour ago
and then if you go over there this is
why they get scanned they get their time
all NHS staff and volunteers and I think
one of the points of this event is also
promoting that link between exercise and
good mental health now to hear more
about today's event we're joined by
Marcus Elvis who's the Run director
Marcus thanks so much for joining us and
can you tell me a little bit about what
you guys wanted to achieve by this event
today uh well today obviously just a
celebration of 75 years of the NHS as
you mentioned we're one of only two Park
runs actually the tape plate on an NHS
site but specifically for us as this is
a psychiatric hospital that we're
located within we're really trying to
sort of help uh establish stronger links
between exercise and good good mental
health so this park runs been running
for four years now and we're very proud
of the fact that you know it is seen as
a a good place to you know establish
that link going forward and just briefly
to someone might be a little bit daunter
they might not be feeling very feared
they might feel oh God I can't do a 5k
just very briefly what would you say to
them Oh Come Along honestly um you know
people walk this we actually have tail
Walkers so you'll never come last it's
enormously inclusive everybody's
incredibly encouraging you don't need to
be intimidated you can take your time
and you know we are here to help you in
any way we can so please come along
enjoy it thank you so much Marcus thank
you so yeah so you can start slow you
can build it up in beautiful grounds
here slightly too hot a day but still
these Runners are doing pretty good time
fantastic Milena it's a great event and
I love the idea of a tail Walker I think
I could do with the tail Runner every
time I go running
yeah anyway belena thank you
nothing a South London Brewery it says
it's the first of a kind to produce a
carbon negative beer without using
carbon offsetting it's using barley
grown through regenerative farming and
it's recapturing the Hops that they're
using Tom heaples while it may not look
like at this point is a little bit
different Brewers here in South London
believe it's the first carbon negative
Point without using any offsets like
tree planting
possibly too early I've got to earn it
and why have you done this yeah we've
made this product because we want to
make great tasting beers that are
helping solve our climate crisis can you
show me how it's done yeah let's go have
a look
secret is in the barley they're using
this is the barley that we use to make
the beer it's been grown in fields with
polycrops three different crops there's
no tilling there's no pesticides
herbicides none of that it's natural
when it comes to climate change what's
the difference between this barley and
normal so normal Bali per day for us has
of common footprint of about one ton of
CO2 whereas this barley has a comfort
print of minus seven tons
great for the ingredients all about the
process let's go and see we've got an
innovation that we're doing next door
which is recapturing the Hops that we
use so the Bears coming through this
machine
the beer and creating this dry powder
work
so those are hops that have been used
already when we use hops we're generally
throw half of it away like an orange cut
it in a half we choose one half we'll
throw the other half away we're just
capturing that other half and making
sure we use that too
reducing the carbon intensity of beer
needs attention from growing of the
ingredients all the way through to the
brewing and the packaging and that's why
it's such a hard goal to reach Ben has
crunched the numbers what is carbon
negative here and what isn't yeah just
the beer and the kegs as a packaging
type at the moment is carbon negative
we're looking to roll that out across
the cans and the beer and the cans as
well but it's going to take some changes
to packaging style and operationally to
get that down so what is it that makes
the the kegs carbon negative and
potentially not the cows yeah so keg
beer kegs are actually reusable so
they're just washed out and cleaned
comparatively to the cans that have to
be recycled which is energy intensive
which subsequently means a mission
intensive as well
I promised I'll be back
this beer is 10 more expensive so is the
demand there it's not just this Brewery
they're doing this we've seen some big
Brewers getting on this act they must
think there's an advantage there yes
certainly I think moving towards carbon
neutral or moving towards carbon
negative is something which is going to
be increasingly important for breweries
the government have got set legal
targets by 2050 for all businesses to be
net zero emissions do we know if
customers are prepared to pay a little
bit more for climate friendly beer yet
um I don't know if we know the answer to
that exactly but we're we're certainly
seeing I mean the way that Gypsy Hill
have done it is to be really forward in
the way they're promoting to be you know
they're selling it as a carbon negative
lager they're putting it in there in The
Branding it's about educating consumers
helping them understand why if you use
higher quality ingredients if you use
lower environmental impact ingredients
then that is ultimately going to produce
a better beer but a lower impact beer
that's perhaps worth a bit more money
with breweries now also on the conveyor
belt towards net zero could green a
pints soon be pulled at your local Tom
heat Sky News South London
now the global shipping industry
accounts for three percent of all gases
that cause climate change well now in a
unanimous agreement 175 countries have
pledged to read net reach Net Zero by
2050. well the deal has been hailed as a
positive step but environmental groups
say it doesn't go far enough our climate
change correspondent to Hannah Thomas
Peter reports cargo ships are the
lifeblood of international trade but
it's a polluting business and this hard
to regulate industry has been under
pressure to clean up
now the United Nations International
Maritime organization known as the IMO
has promised for the first time to get
shipping to Net Zero carbon emissions by
or around 2050.
as you know the maritime
decarbonization strategy
has been one of the most important topic
for last over 10 years
shipping emissions are currently a big
problem global Shipping carries about 90
percent of the world's traded goods and
produces nearly three percent of all
carbon emissions about the same as
emitted by Germany every year for some
then any progress is good news what was
agreed here at the IMO in London is
the first time ever that we have a
greenhouse gas emission strategy a
decarbonization of shipping the
international shipping industry it's a
very important sector we can't say we're
ever going to abandon shipping anytime
soon it's we know that's for thousands
of years but we need to decarbonate but
as temperatures continue to rise this
week setting Global records for the
hottest days ever recorded campaigners
say the Imo's pledge is to vague weak
and lacks a delivery plan we expected
them to
um to come up with goals targets for the
global Shipping sector uh in line with
what it takes for their fair share for
the world to limit warming to 1.5
degrees
and unfortunately they missed a boat on
that the fuels and technology that would
drive any transition are still a long
way off for this critical industry its
journey to Net Zero likely to be an
imperfect one
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News
and you can hear more about climate and
the environment on the climate Show with
Tom Heap that's at 3 P.M and 7 30 p.m
both today and tomorrow here on Sky News
right now let's take a look at the
weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well thunderstorms will push across
Britain and Ireland today giving some
torrential downpours and possibly
causing some disruption this morning
will be hot and humid for Central and
Eastern Parts but some of us are already
seeing some showers this morning those
showers will intensify as they push
North East
the Met Office a warning that the
torrential rain and Gusty winds could
cause some disruption East Anglia should
remain largely dry until the afternoon
and temperatures cut in 33 degrees
Centigrade making it the hottest day of
the year so far
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
you're watching Sky News breakfast
coming up
[Music]
I'll be speaking to Natalie Rushdie
who's just released that single to raise
money for the bow babe Fund in memory of
Dame Deborah James
foreign
[Music]
I think octopuses are fascinating in a
number of different ways probably one of
the things that's interesting about them
is they're sort of considered in some
ways an honorary vertebrate in the sense
that they're closely related to the
other mollusks which are snails and
slugs but they're very fast in their
behavior and they act a little bit
um like many of the vertebrates do and
we sort of have this pride of place as
vertebrates ourselves and so they're
very interesting but distantly related
animal to us they're similar to humans
in many ways because all animals are we
have very common things that run very
deep in evolutionary history amongst the
animals and so you know we all
um we all need food we all fear
predators and look for shelter we all
need to find mates for the most part so
there's some very deep animal
commonalities but there's been some
recent work in outside of my field but
related to octopuses that have shown
that they're um they're some of their
brain functions some of their genetics
uh are doing things that are very
similar to what uh what we do uh
octopuses use this um this reaching
behavior in a number of different ways
and one of the ways that they uh use
this behavior is to sort of reach out
and investigate or sometimes discourage
um to discourage other animals that are
investigating the food the octopus is
working on and so
um you know I wasn't involved in that
study
um but but that's that's generally
what's going on I made a documentary
with uh
PBS here in the United States and BBC
uh over your way that uh in BBC I always
believe it was called
um the octopus in my uh living room and
uh it's an exploration of of octopuses
but from a particular point of view that
that I found interesting which is how do
they relate to other animals they're
they're famously solitary and yet you
know we uh I kept an octopus in the
house and my daughter and I took care of
her and um you know she really seemed to
to uh be very engaged in interacting
with us and it raises some interesting
questions to me about why is this
solitary animal also so skilled at
interacting with other beings foreign
[Music]
now the singer Natalie Rushdie has
worked with 25 musicians to record a
version of tell me it's not true from
the musical Blood Brothers to honor her
friend Dame Deborah James and raise
money for the bowel babe fund it was
released on Monday to mark one year
since Deborah's death after battling
with bowel cancer so let's take a quick
listen to Natalie's new single
[Music]
will come soon
foreign
[Music]
it sounds fantastic the images there are
so moving of course so tell us how this
single came about so Deborah and I have
been friends for absolute years we were
introduced by our husbands who actually
lived together in their 20s and the last
outing she had out was at Royal ASCO
after we made a pack we both had sepsis
at the same time and we said if we
survived it we would go to Ascot
together and that's where she said can
you sing at my funeral and she said
please can you sing my favorite song
which was tell me it's not true from
Blood Brothers oh that's incredibly
touching and and you you did a cool
thing at her funeral
how was that I mean obviously a huge
honor to be asked to do it for someone
who made such an impact on everybody's
lives even the people who didn't know
her but it must have been very hard to
do as well it was incredibly hard I
remember the day it was just beautiful
it was exactly like what she wanted her
funeral to be like and I remember when
she came and I was just hysterical and I
sort of had to bring myself together
because I wanted to give that to my
friend she had asked me and I knew all
of her friends and family were there and
I thought it was so important to give
them her song you know you have to kind
of find those reserves even though it
must be so emotional for you as well and
tell us then about this single because
you've had quite a lot of people coming
forward and saying we want to help you
with this because it's such a good cause
yeah so we had Abbey Road Studio came on
board we've had 25 musicians that came
aboard and then when we released it the
week before Prince William came behind
and gave his support which I thought was
absolutely amazing that a royal is still
campaigning for her Legacy and also the
fact that Royal is talking about Pooh
which you know 20 years ago my nana died
of cancer 20 years ago that just
wouldn't happen that someone of royalty
would talk about Pooh and then Princess
of Wales and I met her at Wimbledon and
I thanked her and she said it was so
important for them to get behind this
charity single well that's right and
that kind of reminds I mean you've seen
the pictures here you can see her sense
of humor apart from anything else and
the way she wanted to break down those
the stuffiness around it and some of
those taboos about talking about this
subject because and then she's dressed
up as a poo there I mean she had a great
sense of humor but a really important
message she was really amazing she just
broke down barriers she sort of broke
down the door and said hang on everyone
let's talk about the brown cancer she
would say it's not attractive and she
would you know she really campaigned for
research and people talking I mean she
would do mad things that dress up as a
poo and but she was such a wonderful
friend and she really did advocate for
everyone who was suffering with bowel
cancer and she sort of United a group of
people that had never spoken before so I
think thanks to her is that we can carry
on her Legacy and what was she like when
he first met her
she was just completely wild and mad and
she just had this wonderful zest for
life she was so joyful and I remember I
was introduced to her by my husband and
she said hi I'm Deborah I've got cancer
I've got bowel cancer and then the last
thing she would say is check your poo
whenever you sort of had a phone call
today bye Cheerio and then she'd go
check your poo and that was just always
her message and I think for me she was
so into science science research and
just making sure that people really
really talked about bowel cancer well
that's right and she now has this
Foundation still raising money and
raising awareness and and that's really
all the processes you say go towards
that don't they so it's very important
so we've had absolutely no costs and
everyone has come on board and done
everything knowing her story and wanting
to help so all of the money directly
goes to the bow Bay fund so please
please download share and so we can keep
on going and how's it doing the single
it's going really well it's at the
moment we just found out yesterday that
it reached the chart the official chart
and number 10 and so we're in the top 10
which is just amazing and the iTunes
chart we were number one so I can't
believe we're amongst Kylie Minogue and
things like that with no record company
and just basically all advocating for
her and that's obviously a tribute to
you and your fantastic voice but but a
real tribute to her as well definitely
she's definitely been sparing me on oh
that's fantastic and you mentioned that
you both got sepsis at the same time how
did that happen to you so I got covered
and then unfortunately it turned into
sepsis so I was in hospital for two
weeks and with basically
um at one point the consultant came in
and I said am I going to survive this he
said I don't know so and she also went
through that so it was our pack to do
Ascot together so and you're in hospital
at the same time yes not the same
Hospital not the same hospital we didn't
actually know that we had sepsis until
much later when we started talking about
it and so what was that like when you
did go to Ascot together it was a time
later bittersweet because she was such a
wonderful person and she had the spark
in her eye but it was literally the week
before she passed away so she was so
incredibly unwell but she messaged me
and her mother messaged me afterwards
and said Natalie she's had such a
wonderful time and that was a perfect
way to say goodbye it wasn't we had a
glass of champagne and we were drinking
cake well eating cakes and having lovely
sandwiches and we were talking about all
the good times and she was still
campaigning even though she was so
unwell she was like we're gonna do this
we're going to do this we're going to
change and she said Natalie I don't want
to die and that really broke my heart
and then she said please can you carry
on my legacy please keep on pushing so I
think with her family and everyone and
the Balboa fund we really are still
pushing for her Legacy yeah and this
single must mean so much to her family
definitely it's been lovely it was
really important to me that we had their
full support before we went ahead and
recorded recorded it and then Alistair
and James her parents and Allison
Heather rather
um came with us to Abby Road Studios and
spoke to the musicians and why it was so
important that this song was chosen for
her oh well we wish you best of luck
with it Natalie thank you so much for
coming in and telling us a little bit
about us and it and I think everyone
really connected or
felt that Deborah's message came through
loud and strong she had such personality
behind it as well didn't she
um really lovely to meet you thanks so
much for coming in thank you
do stay with us here on Sky News coming
up U.S President Joe Biden defends his
decision to provide plus the bombs to
Ukraine more on that coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello watching Sky News I'm Nick Croatia
here are the headlines it's 10 o'clock
President Biden defends his decision to
send cluster bombs to Ukraine and says
Kiev is running out of ammunition
a grieving mum criticizes a horrendous
tweet by Kent Police using a Top Gun GIF
after her daughter's death
of people investigating crimes on